[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
welcome kids to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i am mark bernard hey
oh
pardon me while i take a drink of
something with my face on it new do it
do it
doing it and doing it and doing it well
delicious it is a cherry pie chronicon
cannabis seltzer mark by the good
friends our good friends that uh
had to
be kind so what is called mightycon
um how's everybody doing man it's
[ __ ] hot
unbelievably hot where we are i'm in a
room with no air conditioning i have a
little ass fan and it's blowing hot air
right the [ __ ] at me
this is gonna be the quickest fat man
beyond we ever [ __ ] did i'll tell you
that right now
before we say a [ __ ] word
first a word from our sponsor mark
who's helping us out tonight who's
paying the bills how are we keeping the
lights on well the people helping us
keep the lights on but apparently in
your case not the air conditioning on i
know
are the
one of them our first sponsor the good
folks at native deo
we've talked about a native quite a bit
haven't we yet we do we love the good
folks at native deo man
go to nativedeo.com
right now
slash fatman is that the address yeah or
use the promo code fatman at checkout
uh check out their products man native
makes damn good stuff what i enjoy is
that you know we talk about them on the
show with their sponsors we we hype them
uh i i love their products my wife
swears by them but periodically when
we're not like doing the show like
throughout the week you'll get tweets
from people who are like you guys must
be working because i bought some native
when it rocks and they don't hashtag
native and i'm like oh it'd be so
so much better first if you did however
i don't care i was just happy to read
that like whatever we say has impact we
gotta be careful with our words mark
now put a dollar bill kids in an
envelope and send them in to mark and
kev in hollywood exactly let's soupy
sales this [ __ ] man make ourselves
[ __ ] rich
uh the good folks at native are are one
of our sponsors tonight ladies and
gentlemen they make some of the finest
deodorant products they make great body
wash hair wash which i believe you your
people call shampoo
they they make uh
this [ __ ]
it smells like [ __ ] candy canes
sometimes or just birthday cake this is
a great company man they make vegan
[ __ ] products vegan friendly i
wouldn't recommend eating them but
you're good
because they're made from plants
don't you get it not from some
artificial chemical [ __ ] they're
made from plants
nativedeo.com
fat man what are you waiting for how
many times you got to tell you this
native g-e-o
dot com slash fat man you can get how
much off mark 20 off the first order
[ __ ] the road to being a millionaire
begins with 20 off at
nativedeo.com ladies and gentlemen slash
fat man we thank the good folks at
native uh deodorant uh for being proud
sponsors of this year's show
fat man beyond
indeed i i would like to caution you
listeners that it will not make you a
millionaire
yeah i just saw a movie that says you
know it's not the machine
it's the man in the box
i've watched maverick top gun too you
finally watched it
that [ __ ] is bomb though right
i'm wonderful but you know you know what
wonderful it's true i i'm not i
mean good
just real good just exactly what it
needed to be
um
thing that i was most impressed by is
tom cruise is 60.
again taking a shirt off with a bunch of
children on the beach
exactly not just taking a shirt off
taking a shirt off in front of people 30
years is [ __ ] junior and [ __ ] like
that still pulling off i'm [ __ ]
running around playing football
you know and in the [ __ ] in on the
beach
it's hard enough running running when
i'm 52 i'd never run unless i was chased
and even then i'd be like look i'll suck
your dick to stop chasing me
you have to run this guy's like tom
cruising down the beach catching the
football and [ __ ] like that
and then and listen to us we're like oh
my god he can play football he [ __ ]
flies jets in the movie for real
like he takes off and it's him and i i
think green screen he's [ __ ]
literally doing this [ __ ]
it's crazy uh but yeah that's totally a
watchable movie do you like how the
middle of it was just star wars
pretty much yeah it's like you got to
navigate this trench and you're gonna
launch a missile through an exhaust
report this big
top tom cruise impressive uh you know
the dude who played uh rooster what's
his name miles
keller
impressive
jennifer conley
do you know how old jennifer connelly is
uh i don't but i'm going to guess
50 [ __ ] two she's my age yeah
mark why don't i look like jennifer
conley why can't i act like jennifer
conley how come i'm not married to paul
bettany like jennifer connolly why do
the jennifer conleys of this world get
[ __ ] everything mark and i get
nothing
uh my my favorite thing is that when you
first meet um jennifer connolly's
character in the bar that she owns
uh david
penny [ __ ] don't serve her
identities penny you know his name's
maverick because everybody [ __ ] says
it
literally everybody said nobody ever
calls him [ __ ] pete his name's pete
well if you could go by maverick and
your name was pete wouldn't you go by
maverick
maverick there's a little cringe to be
named maverick right it's like you're
thirsty for it like trying too hard like
let me call you a maverick don't you
call yourself a maverick that's what
that's the thing you can't pick your own
call sign your call sign has to be
dubbed upon you oh so somebody else
called them maverick that's that's that
apparently is the law of a call sign
like you can't just decide you want to
be called [ __ ] hot shot or whatever
you know what you just improved the
movie for me about three percent
but the first time you see penny in the
bar um there's a bowie song on the
jukebox
because jennifer connolly was elaborate
with david bowie
oh there's a bowie song i thought you
said there's a bone saw on the jukebox
and i was like what version of top gun
did you see because
lots of questions was it was it saw nine
maverick
uh bowie song yes whole time we were
watching the movie i kept saying to my
my wife like i'd roll over and she
wasn't next to me she was on the couch i
was in the bed but i was watching this
way and i'd roll over
and i would be like um
you know
she ain't going to be impressed by this
guy she met the goblin king
child
why aren't you talking about that you
know
talking about like you broke up with me
at one point maverick instead be like i
met the goblin king he tried to kidnap
my brother that pedo [ __ ] and my god he
had a [ __ ] cod piece
i was a child a teenager
i was surrounded by puppets
uh i also i saw a little movie this
weekend as well what'd you say i saw 3
000 years of longing
oh i just saw that trailer as a george
miller movie right the george miller
picture i'm starting idris elba and
tilda swinton i just saw that trailer
what i got from the trailer is uh idris
elba is a genie is that correct yes
so it's like adult aladdin i believe
that's what they said in the trailer
pretty much
um it looked visually arresting how was
it um it's uh it's fine
it oh nice
it's it's got an interesting uh couple
of acts
um in which
tilde mark we're trying to build a
profile for this [ __ ] show yeah what
are we gonna do well in order to get on
a movie poster you can't say [ __ ] like
it's fine
mark bernardin batman beyond
to be clear you almost said the exact
same thing about maverick
it's a movie
yeah i acknowledge the fact that it has
credits
i just know i feel like i went too far i
was like it was wonderful and and really
like i got to save that for [ __ ] that i
truly feel
was like paper girls was wonderful
um you know maverick was was maverick it
was pretty pretty much exactly what it
needed to be well made i'm not saying
like joe kizenski needs to go back to
film school or something like incredibly
well made but
i i'll be honest with you and i know
this is not [ __ ]
patriotic or whatever [ __ ] but like i
wasn't a big
top gun kid saw it once
ever ever
in my life so i'm going on this one
going like where'd she come from is that
who's this that keller who tells his
daughter like where's she how does she
figure into this where's kelly mcgillis
that's all i kept saying oh oh i fell
asleep that night that all night long i
kept tossing and turning where's going
to go and then i wake myself up
um so yeah it's it's
oh [ __ ] speaking of where's kelly
mcgillis yeah you know where [ __ ] val
kilmer was
very touching val kilmer [ __ ]
beautiful
really nice they found a way to get him
in there and do him justice um
you know it was they really played up
that relationship it's like those dudes
just shook shook hands at the end of the
movie
they weren't like this and then years
later they're like it was you can be
you'd be my wingman any time i'll be
yours you'd be mine oh all right good
point well that's as i said i saw the
movie once
when it came out
[Laughter]
my memory is a little rusty i do
remember the wingman thing but uh but
yeah no totally
movie movie what a movie what a movie um
but yeah a few thousand years of long
it's beautiful because it's [ __ ]
george miller and he had money to spend
on it and so to to have a genie tell you
the tales that led him inside a lamp is
actually kind of interesting
um and and tilda swinton as a woman who
does not have a heart's desire to choose
for herself what she wants to wish for
is also interesting
um it's just when she makes her wish the
movie kind of dissolves a little bit as
it goes and it just it kind of loses
what snap it had
um
i mean i enjoyed myself but it was it
was one of those movies where it was a
little frustrating because you saw what
the sort of better movie of that version
was
you just made it left or right or left
but isn't that how you view i mean it
might then you must be frustrated all
the time because you always come up with
a better movie anyway where you're like
oh i saw this but you know what would
have made it better
[ __ ] gold ingots
why didn't anyone think to throw in the
gold ingots well i mean there's movies
that are just like bad
we're like all right you know what they
could have done a hundred different
things and came up with a better movie
or done a completely different story
speaking of which clerks three coming to
theaters very soon kids get your tickets
clear
dot movie
anyway
um oh yeah this was just you know
incredibly talented people at work
you know actors who are who are just
working the way that we know that they
can work talented performers but it just
was it fell apart a little bit the
center did not hold but it's when he got
to the end
and those are the movies that are that
are more frustrating than others to me
because they were close they just sort
of missed the mark
um literally and figuratively i'm trying
to think if i watched anything
like new did i watch a movie this week
we did what did we watch
it's not i fell asleep watching it but
that doesn't mean anything i was just
super [ __ ] tired
um
[ __ ]
i forget i stayed awake all through top
gun though
so
that's that's my movie [ __ ] pull
quote for a poster i stayed awake
through this entire movie kevin smith
at once
some people would be like what kind of
praise is that he's like do you know
this guy he's sleepier than the [ __ ]
door mouse
watching movies like movies beginning he
just [ __ ] twinkle tweet
so if he said he stayed awake well by
gum i got to see that movie myself nine
stars
um
yeah i've just been getting ready all
week man i know you're going on tour
what what are the preparations for
embarking on a months-long road show
honestly
i mean you won't be real yeah you got to
make sure you got weed plenty of weed
there
come on man like i look i tell everyone
i'll go anywhere you want as long as
there's weed where they're
where i'm going
if i get where i'm going and there's no
weed
that's why you'll never catch me in
russia
um so
uh packing but i packed light
i mean let's be honest i wear like one
outfit all the time anyway and [ __ ]
i'm probably on tour i'll be wearing you
know what i'm going to wear my jacket
that i wore the premiere um
because i instead of wearing the purple
jacket everyone's always giving me [ __ ]
about the purple jacket so i was like
fine i'll now replace it with this black
and white jacket but this is the tour
shirt so i'll probably be and this is
why i don't have to bring a lot of
[ __ ] luggage every night i'm on stage
every night i come grab one of the tour
shirts from the merch even if this one
gets stinky
this is the tour shirt so
it's the shirt that randall
in the movie uh as portrayed by jeff
anderson
uh randall has his heart attack in it is
uh designed drawn of course by the great
uh dark nate
himself dark naked zoz who does our
artwork for the show um and it was off
of an idea that i was like who tried
this and then he
[ __ ]
just brought magic to it and [ __ ] so
it's a truly truly is our fake gum in
the in in the movie from clerks and
stuff so this is
suck me off and make me gum
chuli's
uh gum
sucker
it's meant to be a
a lollipop right like a [ __ ] blow pop
oh yeah
that's clear and look at that i don't
know if you can see that mark but
that looks kind of familiar and at the
bottom it says
gum in your mouth
so come in chocolate
of course no we actually made it just in
the blue
because that's what he wears in the
movie yeah why actually had a discussion
about what color shirt it should be on i
was like i don't know if you watched the
movie when you want the shirt that was
in the movie on the back as
clerks three
um
i assure you i was there for the
convenience tour fall
2022. so that's
the worst shirt when the folks do vip
that's just taking pictures with me they
get a copy of the screenplay that was
that we made just for the tour man no
nice nice man it's crazy how anybody
could just make a book now
um
i'm all for that world man it's so
democratic so diplomatic everybody gets
to make a book uh they put i put the
screenplay in here man it's got some
[ __ ] that was not in the movie and stuff
um
we uh
shows are [ __ ] selling out philly i
believe just sold out
um we are about to sell out the second
jersey show um it's uh it's been great
and uh you know they the fathom events
screenings have been going
well in pre-sales so much so that they
extended our run we were supposed to be
two nights september 13th and september
15th
but fathom's like the demand is so high
we're going to extend you right into the
weekend so we got a friday and a
saturday
so uh september 13th through the
september 18th you can go see it in a
movie theater near you or you can see it
with me on the convenience tour man
starting
this sunday
[ __ ] [ __ ] three days from now
in the great state in new jersey in red
bank just down the street from jay and
zombov secret stash at the basey count
basie theater the basie center they call
it and now and then we go
from uh new jersey to
uh portland maine
and then to uh the keswick in philly
outside of philly
um then we go up to providence rhode
island then to new york new york the
beacon theater
washington dc the warner theater and
then we go to uh
virginia richmond virginia
we sold out a show there and said we
added a second show as well then
september 13th we stopped touring
because that's when the movie's on the
fathom screens
and i go do press in new york so i'm
gonna be on seth meyers our mutual
friend seth meyers tell him i say hello
i will i'm gonna be like you remember
that [ __ ] dude talking about comic
books i know that guy
um we're so i'll see him i think i'm
doing the view while i'm there as well
um a bunch of like new york kind of
press and stuff uh as the movie comes
out that week as it plays once a night
on a fathom events screen and uh then uh
i've got hollywood babylon here in los
angeles on september 16th and then the
18th i head back up to vancouver and the
tour resumes um at the rio theater and
then we move on to colorado so forth and
so on i'm gonna be on the road
for a while my friend i might come back
like everyone periodically like i'm back
here to do
the la show the san diego show the
sacramento show
anaheim show
um and that's like in late september
early october
but generally speaking i'm on the road
until at least thanksgiving now don't
mean we can't do this because look
you could be anywhere i could literally
be anywhere i could do this in the [ __ ]
or
you wouldn't want that
so loud and squishy but uh but i could
be done um so yes we will continue to do
uh fat man beyond which i'm sure will be
me telling you like oh my god guess what
happened this week i showed the movie
seven [ __ ] times so
we're going to have to rely on you for
news stories because my story the same
story over and over what'd you do this
week i showed the movie to 8 000 people
i watched clerks a lot let me tell you
something i i'm glad i love this movie
because i'm about to watch the [ __ ] out
of it and i do i watch it every night
because i watch the audience i'm a dirty
little cuck like i'm watching them watch
the thing i'm like look at them being
pleasured and i stand there inside and
[ __ ] watch them the whole time
sometimes i shoot them from behind with
my with my camera like shoot the
audience reacting to the movie and stuff
i make another movie while we watch the
movie and i don't even ask for their
permission to be in the movie [ __ ] it
they're in the movie
you did it i incepted them into my movie
um so
i look forward to uh life on the road
man this was well because of the jay and
silent bob reboot roadshow tour i was
like oh man this is awesome wouldn't it
be great if i like if they like this
what if i took clerks three out on the
road and that kind of made me go all
right as soon as we get home from this
tour
2020 we're going to [ __ ] do j at
clerk's three and we're going to tour it
and then you know [ __ ]
things happen
but we did like get to make a movie and
a pandemic and now it's ready to show
the world uh the word i've received back
from from our screenings is is very
positive mark outstanding yeah it's it's
very it's it's nice so uh
kids
get your tickets clerks three dot movie
whether you're seeing it with me or
you're seeing it without me
go see it man um i know they gave me
some right before the show began they
gave me some very good news
uh that but they don't want me to share
it until they were going to make it like
a press release oven [ __ ] so things are
everything's coming up milhouse man
knock wood so
come on out
come back to the quick stop kids come to
new jersey with me see clerks three
anyway
uh um this coming friday i
am doing the final mix on splinter is
that right where are you doing it
uh a place called formosa here in los
angeles
um i'm familiar with the place yeah and
look at you this is your first mix isn't
it baby's first mix
baby's first mix nobody mixes baby in
the corner
how much time you got one day or
something
yeah yeah like half a day um
yeah between
the better part of the day but yeah man
like we finished color grading last
weekend
um so the picture's solid and we just
this is it score's done the effects are
done adr is done and every this is this
is the last stage
then what then what
then we uh we prep it we master it for
both festivals
as well as um internet
dispersion so that the kickstarter
backers can take a look at the thing
that they they help in great part
um become a reality and then we start
applying you start trying to hit the
road um
what um we do the smile castle film
festival in december but i will
look i'm here if you need me but i don't
want to hurt your chances of getting
into say a sundance or something like
that that's the one you should be
focusing on
yeah like that's that's very much part
of the reasons why we're trying to be
done by beginning of september is
that's when deadlines begin and sundance
is traditionally the first one up at the
plate
so it's like sundance and south by um
there's a there's a palm spinning
springs shorts fest
um
you know not that where it will apply to
[ __ ]
and we won't get in and i probably
couldn't afford to go even if we did but
we'll we'll try and get in
this is what we could do too um i know a
guy owns a movie theater so we can
actually
down the road do like a [ __ ]
screening
that we sell tickets to and we do q a
and [ __ ] afterwards yeah absolutely
start earning off that [ __ ] man give
me my money
money
that's why we make art for money kids
there's the truth there's the dirty
truth
i will happily be a seller
um
tried it once
time
yeah i'd rather work for my money uh
because especially because the work is
so
gratifying literally self-gratifying
because the work is me so basically i
jerk off for a living
i jerk off for a living and nobody has
to ever look at my dick nobody will ever
see it mark i'll keep it hidden right
it's right there on your t-shirt man
on the the clerk's porsche
yeah i guess you're
right
um
um did you watch some television
should we jump into the things we
watched let me tell you i would love to
[ __ ] talk about
some [ __ ] on television let's do it man
you watch some [ __ ] kids so here's the
part of the show we're going to talk
about that what'd you watch
i have seen now um
all three episodes that exist of shield
i was one down last time we did a
podcast
um and i really like this episode like
this episode was
it felt like the rhythms the show kind
of wanted to be
which is here's our sort of like
overarching case the emil blonsky parole
thing
we drop in little wong and wang is just
being funny and cool and long is going
to be the nick fury of this version of
the avengers
bet if he's the one who gathers
everybody either for the thunderbolts or
for whatever avengers team for young
avengers at some point whatever it is
here for it um
got a little tiny one-shot legal runner
about a a nice guardian shape-shifting
fairy elf
who cool story that felt like
could have been part of the comics right
there didn't have to be like oh my god
that's
that character from issue blah blah blah
it's just general asgardian
you know enough of a connection to our
to our mythos while still being a
standalone kind of thing i went for it
yeah like i dug it you know and um
and then they picked the perfect kind of
cad
to be the victim of this particular
lawsuit
because he's a dude that you love to
hate and they find a nice reversal on
him being an [ __ ] an awful person who
is going to get so he's going to win
this lawsuit because he's so awful
like i sort of dug that um
i will say my biggest stumbling block of
this episode
was the the
jen walters cg
like
the first couple of minutes of that was
there were there there were a few
moments where i too was like um you know
because i'm i don't
you know me i'm like i can't make a
[ __ ] she-hulk so good on you but
there were a few moments where i was
like why don't they hire a very like
tall woman for the wide shots
and just
face you know plants
like just
um you know it feels like
the
the walking stuff
which you know they like to show off
dude simple walk and talk which is like
one of the cheapest things to do
on a tv show becomes inordinately
expensive because
a person who's not there
has to be doing the walking so i assume
they've got tatiana
maslany
on stilts like they would do to you know
[ __ ]
brolin
jeff
josh brolin
as thanos remember you see behind the
scenes videos and he's in these
ridiculous high boots and [ __ ] like that
yeah i guess they got her doing that and
then they replace her entirely or
whatever but it just feels like you
could probably get a very tall woman
for most of the shots and then just cg
on top of it what do i know i don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] but
there were a few moments where i was
like uncanny uncanny
yeah it's like
it's not checking me out not where i was
like oh [ __ ] this you know i was just
like
they're on a deadline
i get it that cake wasn't baked yet but
you do what you got to do sometimes man
it's okay if it's a little doughy inside
i don't mind but yeah i mean it's funny
i was i was talking to somebody uh over
the weekend about aliens
and they were like yeah you know the
movie really holds up it means some of
the cg is a little rocky and i was like
bro there's no cg in that movie he's
made 96
like it was made in 85 or at least in 86
there's no cd in this [ __ ] there's
some rear projection shots in that
[ __ ] movie
on a giant screen and then they're doing
[ __ ] in front of it that's how they used
to drive in the 40s and 50s in movies it
is incredibly old school
not cg though it's the opposite
it's camera trickery yeah like lots of
model work you know a little bit of
green screen stuff but
you know like there's still an old
school way to do jen walters that
doesn't require her to be cg every time
you see her
because i'm 100 sure there's some wnba
athletes who would happily put on a
business suit and walk around an office
for you and get you all of that body
motion right get you all of that
physicality right
without needing to to drop it through a
processor
um
but you know
i think tatiana is still very good and i
think the scripts are very strong and i
think that this feels the way this show
wants to feel um
this is like the proof of concept more
than the pilot or even the second
episode was and so like yeah [ __ ] it's
funny i dig it let's go
i'm happy for there to be a megan v
stallion cameo if it gets people to
watch
an episode of sheehan
um yeah that part was fun
um i enjoy her and i enjoy like i i want
her to break the fourth wall more
but that's not a complaint you know [ __ ]
please don't
write and [ __ ] that like smith [ __ ]
that
she hope not good enough not at all i
like she hulk i think it's it's
absolutely fun and it's you hey
here's something i couldn't say about
top gun maverick it's wonderful it's
wonderful
um yeah so i've been digging it my only
complaint is like come on man [ __ ]
drop them all and [ __ ] this like under
30 [ __ ] like
you know just when it's like right on
it's getting going and then it [ __ ]
stops and [ __ ] uh is daredevil next week
does anybody know uh i don't know i
don't know they've been very cagey about
when they're going to be revealing the
rest of the guest stars we're going to
get i look forward to that man i look
forward to seeing charlie cox do some
dialogue again man i don't see
what he you know we've seen
matt murdock
you know in the marvel cinematic
universe i want to see how daredevil
plays
in
the marvel cinematic universe
particularly this iteration of the
marvel cinematic universe which is very
lighthearted yeah
and that that guy daredevil comes from a
show where there was one scene where
kingpin
slammed a guy's head in the in a [ __ ]
tr in a suv door
until he [ __ ] beheaded him
that was the implication they didn't
show that i mean but you heard it and
the implication was his [ __ ] head
came off completely now we've seen an
iteration of kingpin wearing a big
hawaiian shirt and you know that tracks
with the comics so that's great
um we saw him
the same guy who beheaded somebody
fight
what's his name hayley
fight a child yeah that's quite a
[ __ ] kid
i'm curious what so i'm so curious how
what daredevil's first appearance
is going to be like tonally um and i'm
okay if he makes jokes because i thought
charlie cox was funny on daredevil not
like oh [ __ ] you know [ __ ] give him a
sitcom but like he could call him
yeah he could pull up [ __ ] humor
while he was pulling off
drama he's a very deft performer yeah so
i'm looking forward to that and i'm not
like
i'm not like they better do it right
whatever they do is [ __ ] right by me
they brought the right guy back that's
all i care about i mean i think that
that perhaps this
episode's iteration of the wrecking crew
can maybe uh
give a little bit of an insight as to
how the brutality or lack thereof of
kingpin will sort of happen yeah we meet
the wrecking crew at the end of this
thing and it just felt like a bunch of
draft dodgers who got their hands on
magic stuff
and and handily got their asses bit by a
person with no combat training at all
um
but there was the like the guy who tried
to stab her to get her blood who then
says the boss is going to be really
angry that we didn't get the sample he
wanted i can't help but think that that
boss might be the kingpin you think so i
was wondering that but i'm like can't be
kingpin but i guess maybe if daredevil
is going to show up yeah why would
kingpin want her blood so he can hulk
out
um so that would help out so he can yeah
he can sell it he can give it to
somebody that he loves he can
whatever that is
there's there's a usage i can imagine
for a criminal mastermind to have
bulk blood i like that writing where
it's just like he could give it somebody
loves that's a good storyline
you can't never do he's committing a
crime and being horrible but it's
because he's trying to help somebody
i mean that's that's how we've seen them
introduce and play kingpin for very much
of both the netflix version
and in the sony version and then the
books what was the uh
was it the the one that frank miller
wrote and
drew was about daredevil love and war
um
i want i believe it's daredevil love and
war and it tells the story of um
kingpin and it's that design that they
used or kind of mimicked for into the
spiders where he's just [ __ ] gigantic
phil cenkevich is a [ __ ] genius
and
he kidnaps
a doctor a psychiatrist therapist
brings him up to like the top of his
building and he's making him work
with vanessa
his wife
who has been like detached from reality
or going through something
and you know it's he just waxes
poetically about how much he loves
vanessa
and you know meanwhile he's like talking
to the psychiatrist like cure her or you
get killed ugly like you know he's just
being the villain that he is
and i remember i'll never forget that
the powerful [ __ ] ending is like
he's working with
the woman kingpin loves
and
you know she
communicates using he brings in
children's blocks with letters and
starts moving them and basically she
spells out
um x
c a
p e if i remember correctly i think it
says escape
and kingpin has to see that like he has
to see like she
this guy who's like vanessa the my heart
of my heart
she's terrified of him and she does not
want to be anywhere [ __ ] near him and
stuff and daredevil has to climb
the [ __ ] tower to get a fist tower to
get up there and stuff and by the end
it's kind of like
it's not a bloody fight he's defeated by
by
his own
the world that he made
not that dissimilar from like you know
what they didn't into the spider verse
where
they show his wife and his kids seeing
him
and like running off and then getting
by yeah horrified by who he really is
um i love that book so [ __ ] much it's
such a great book um
so
anyway yeah daredevil's coming
i just fall down the rabbit hole of
things that i love and i'm like oh my
god like i'll never be reading that book
and then rereading the book and then
rereading the book and it's just got
there's a devastating piece of writing
with the reveal of the blocks where he
said the psychiatrist says something as
written by frank miller i believe says
something to the effect of like you know
i
i defeat him or i end him
with a you know a block or something
like that
it's such a wonderful [ __ ] book
um all right yeah and also did you did
you uh see the second episode of house
of them dragons
on on the hbo i i have not yet um
you know the first one kind of
it's a lot of it's a lot of blonde
to
i gotta get a pair of sunglasses watch
too
um but uh yeah i haven't gotten around
to two did you i did i did you know here
is there a birth of a dragon in this one
um no
no there's there's what happens is matt
smith's um damon targaryen steals a
dragon egg and that seems to be a big um
you know flash point
for the the king his brother for his
niece who is you know
i can't remember raymond rineris
targaryen there's so many of these names
um
but they're about to go to war to
retrieve the dragon egg and uh and and
that's that's sort of the falcon point
of this episode as well as what to do
with the crab dude who's terrorizing the
stepstones
it's a lot of it's a lot of
it's a lot of blonde people in rooms
having meetings
um
meetings that probably could have been a
raven
oh really they could have just sent a
raven it's just a raven just
if it's it's a mean it could be raymond
if it's a raven it could be a a
a regular letter and it was a regular
letter we just didn't need to have it um
and so it's just a bunch of people
talking i mean it's very claustrophobic
show especially in
the locations where we're almost always
just in king's landing
um
at least like
you know and i don't want to compare it
too much to game of thrones which was a
different show clearly a different idea
and had different perspectives um
but but yeah i'm i'm still gonna watch
it because i still do like it
but it uh
it could use a little
more things happening to more people
[ __ ] people in chat are like roasting
me for going like you know
you know [ __ ]
smith says too much blonde in [ __ ]
game of thrones or whatever the [ __ ]
well we were talking beforehand and it
was literally this episode that it
occurred to me not at all during the
previous 48 seasons of game of thrones
that the word aryan is right there in
the middle of targaryen like they're not
even really hiding it that this is
exactly who these people are and it's
like yeah there's a lot of blonde hair
blue eyes and you know i'm not
overwhelmingly sympathetic in general
to uh to to aryans who call themselves
as such
i uh i do look forward to uh
catching up with the show but i think
i'm gonna let a few episodes
um gather up before i return yeah build
up a head of steam if you will
so that i could [ __ ] binge a bunch in
a row um
you know
there you go
all right so we watched some [ __ ] we
watched some [ __ ] um
i think that's all i watched oh i
watched the first two episodes of mike
the mike tyson show that's on hulu how
is it
um it's interesting travante rhodes from
moonlight um is playing mike tyson um
both sort of
in his prime mike tyson and older mike
tyson and the framing device is this
one-man show that mike tyson had um
probably about 10 years ago in which he
basically told the story of his life
through his own perspective
um
and then they have some younger actors
playing you know young mike tyson both
as a sort of 11 12 years old and a 14 15
year old
um
and it's not poorly done at all um the
only issue that it has
is that mike tyson was a phenomenal
physical specimen who could do things in
a boxing thing that nobody else could do
including actors and so it's just hard
to capture that level of of brutality
and speed and power if you don't have
that level of brutality speed and power
so like it's it's pretty decent when
it's outside of the ring but once it's
in the ring you're like oh right
you didn't even speed up the film
um they're i'm sorry they're feeling
very randy in chat charles charlie h
goes smith dot dot dot [ __ ] doofus
jesus charlie h what [ __ ] happened to
you this made me laugh
uh smith says blondes don't have more
fun headline kevin smith says game of
thrones not enough superheroes
this one i don't get bicky bickford says
remember smith cut the line
in 89. i don't know what that means
all i can have in 89 is the batman movie
are they saying i cut the line to get in
the background
you told a story that like one of your
friends waited in line
and you were gonna go see something else
or whatever and you budged a bunch of
people in 1989 i think
on a show like
months ago there was something about
cutting a
i mean here's the real story
here's the real story brian and walter
and ed havstack
were in line uh for batman uh and i was
supposed to work that night literally
across the parking lot
at a dominoes that was my first day on
the job
and um i hated it because they made me
wear pants and um
when they were like oh we have too many
trainees who wants to go home i was like
[ __ ] me
because they had called me at work i
think brian had called me at work to be
like we're going to batman man we're
going to the show blah blah blah are you
coming and i was like i can't i'm at the
[ __ ] place i was like but i might be
able to get off so they were like we'll
hold the place for and [ __ ] and so when
i did get off i drove my car over to the
[ __ ] the two parking lots
found them and got in but i don't
remember
budging people in a [ __ ] line that's
not a cut if your [ __ ] friend holds
your space in a line
so
i say i did not cut the line in 89.
i said i joined the line in 89. it
sounds like some archaic political
campaign slogan
like
uh nixon flew and tyler knew or whatever
the [ __ ]
um
the subtle stealth turk turk cast
the uh
matthew marge says in chat smith
eviscerates pants i'll take that bullet
i would if that gets me canceled [ __ ] it
[ __ ] this whole world if not liking
pants gets me canceled that would be
amazing [ __ ] it to death because i have
a human right an american right not to
like
jorts i mean we get to make choices in
this country still last i checked
can i share a story with you you can uh
because a lot of people online i saw a
lot of news sites i was in the news
recently mark
um we did we've been doing press for
clerks three so there have been clerks
three pieces and stuff uh but the other
day there was lots of
flurry of news activity news sites
um
wondering whether or not it was could
possibly be [ __ ] true
that i was entertaining the notion of
making a
sequel to tusk
the movie that i made years ago that
everyone thought i was batshit crazy for
uh came out and tanked and has since
grown and found a following and uh
art house kids really seemed to like it
and
and um so
there were lots of stories like
this rumor that he's [ __ ] working on
a sequel that couldn't that couldn't
[ __ ] be he would never yeah a lot of
that [ __ ] or why would he or what the
[ __ ] like he just got back on track this
clerk's three picture seems like it's
gonna work out why would he chance it
um
you know
she
does life is
life life was almost short for me a few
years ago i don't want to bring the room
down but i almost died from a heart
attack as we all know gave that heart
attack to randall for the new movie
clerks 3 in september 13th tickets at
clerk's three dot movie
um but ever since the heart attack mark
i've been living like you know
on borrowed time the way i see it and uh
as somebody who's living on borrowed
time i tend to act accordingly so
um i i was uh i wrote a movie that we
presumably will be doing next the 430
movie uh it's the movie that we're going
to shoot in my in the movie theater that
we're buying uh the forthcoming spot
castle cinemas which i just saw the uh
geeky jerseys made our our uniform is
going to be hockey jerseys like of
course
checks out you know what i'm saying uh
and the jersey designs are like [ __ ]
fantastic ernie just sent me a picture
of the marquee uh design that uh captain
ridman did for us
so uh that's gonna be like uh absolute
bliss and because i'm i got this movie
theater i wrote a movie for the movie
theater as if i write uh called the 430
movie and that's what we're going to be
shooting in
2023
2024 will mark the 10-year anniversary
of tusk
and tusk was a movie born on social
media on twitter
yes
and um
everyone on you know that followed me on
my social media like tracked its
movement and its growth and and
only because there was a deal the a24
put the movie out the good folks at 24.
um they had made a deal with sony sony
did uh
well they didn't xyz pictures did
um uh sony did international but part of
the deal was it had to be released
like a real movie release in the states
so a24 put it out on 600 screens the day
we opened with no marketing money
whatsoever they were like but don't you
have social media and it's like
yeah but that ain't that ain't
advertising dollars like
so uh tusk comes out and like dies a
pretty [ __ ] miserable death
and you know we could just leave it
there
and move on but
you know hey i've got more story i'd
like to tell there's a reason we left
him in the zoo at the end
because i always knew as we were making
the movie i was just like oh i'll
totally do this again you know i thought
we'd have the great the late great
michael parks with us longer uh but um
you know sadly he's not but i know we
got justin
and so early on i was always like well
eventually they'll take him out of that
walrus skin and try to rehabilitate him
and you know just like harvey dent in uh
the dark knight returns but he'll only
ever see himself one way and then
[ __ ] he becomes
the howard howe justin long becomes the
[ __ ] crazy guy who's trying to turn
people into
something else chimera things half human
half whatever last time it was walrus
this time we'll see
so
you know i always had that in the back
of my head and [ __ ] and then the movie
died and i was like well i don't think
about this for at least 10 years and
clock's ticking we're almost there so i
would be stupid
not to make
what i'm calling tusks
and yes
just like when jim cameron pitched
aliens
the s in tusks has a dollar sign through
it kids
has everything to do with the plot of
the story but it's also just me nakedly
communicating my ambition
that i am going to correct the past if
you live long enough sometimes you do
[ __ ] just to be like
i i don't think we were wrong i think we
were early great late great jim jackson
was the producer of mall rats when mall
rats came out and died [ __ ] at the
box office we were doing a [ __ ]
postmortem on the movie and i was like i
feel stupid i shouldn't have done that
man i was wrong i thought i was funny
but i was wrong and jim jackson was like
no no no listen to me we weren't wrong
we were early watch and he was right ten
years later i was like holy [ __ ] man
[ __ ] like nobody remembers this movie
flopped except me everyone seems to like
mall ranches jim called it he's the
movie was just i'm not saying we were
out of our time but technically yeah
we were there just a little bit early it
happens sometimes in my career and i
don't give a [ __ ] i like being there
early and stuff it just means you don't
get collect all the plaudits and the the
money first one through the dork takes
all the bullets and [ __ ] like that
but you know i don't mind that i just
like being first sometimes and weird
[ __ ] like that and so
you know that i thought this the [ __ ]
story was written
um but you know i've been in this
business long enough to know the stories
never [ __ ] written as long as you're
above ground jersey girl was a movie
that people were like he's over and
tortured me for and
now it's a movie that people [ __ ] dig
and talk about fondly and [ __ ] like that
like i've watched if you're if you stand
in one place long enough
you know you see all kinds of weather so
i've watched people go from [ __ ] on
mall rats to saying like it's his best
work
um i've watched people go from [ __ ]
non-jersey girl to being like oh my god
why can't you make movies like that
anymore [ __ ] like that so i'm smart
enough to know that tusk has built up a
reputation like all the work that like
you know we did making that weird ass
movie
made it a weird ass movie that people
now know about and stuff and you know
just because last time we were
not wrong just early it just feels like
i could correct that and by doing tusks
i get a second bite at that apple where
i'm like okay
now let's see if we can release it the
way i would like to release it if i'd
had my way i would have toured the
[ __ ] thing it would have been a huge
success
um you know even opening it on one
screen new york and la would have been
great we dumped it
on [ __ ] 600 screens
so
this would be you know i was wondering
like how do i follow up the convenience
tour man because it's like jay and samba
reboot road show was like holy [ __ ] i'm
alive let's have a party uh clerk's
three is holy [ __ ] i'm alive let's
meditate on this and i you know i'm like
what would possibly be next i don't
think i would tour with 430 movie it
doesn't feel like that it feels like a
film festival film
but [ __ ] tusks
oh my god i could tour on that [ __ ]
for like two years if i wanted to man
like it's a midnight movie and a half i
know what the movie is i've seen it i've
been writing it for a long time not like
this but in the head and [ __ ] this is
the last thing and that's [ __ ] easy
so i know how [ __ ] up it's gonna be
and i like i love being in the audience
with people watching the movie and [ __ ]
like that it's going to be batshit
wonderful when we do it with tusks so i
i reached out to the kids
in the movie man i reached out to justin
long genesis rodriguez and and hailey
joel osborne and texts to them all
to be like hey i'm watching tusk
[ __ ] amazing still reminding remains
one of my favorite things i've ever done
your commitment to this bat [ __ ] crazy
script is beyond admirable you're all
acting your asses off as if this movie
is not [ __ ] incredibly stupid god
bless you all i said uh you know two
years from now is the 10-year
anniversary
i said i think it's time we go back i've
got the story to tell and you know you
expect a little pushback
especially from justin who's like you
know [ __ ] like
like brody and jaws too like you know
i've seen a walrus up cloaked
you know and don't [ __ ] you don't
make me go out there because i ain't
going through that hell again
but all of them were just like oh my god
let's [ __ ] do it so um you know in
2024 for the 10-year anniversary of tusk
tusks
with the dollar sign
at the end thank you jim cameron for
that
[ __ ] tale the aliens [ __ ] story
man like uh it's gonna be
a good time some people have been
speculating you know like he's [ __ ]
so far up his own ass i would not
disagree
um but to be fair i have been so far up
my own ass from the first movie you just
didn't know it because you didn't know
my life but clerks is literally just me
doing my life and changing all the
[ __ ] names and [ __ ] so
this is nothing new uh me being way into
kevin smith and up kevin smith's own ass
this is something i've been practicing
since [ __ ] mall rats kids like
technically since clerks so
i look forward to this man i i think
you know i know some people like i hate
the [ __ ] movie i get it like i
totally get it i love i happen to love
that [ __ ] movie but i could
understand why people don't like it but
the people that do [ __ ] love it man
like i i saw what you know i didn't want
to say anything for a minute on social
media but i saw people's reaction and
like there was an incredibly effusive
wave of positivity if people were like
[ __ ] yes do it and it might just be like
i dare you but
you know sometimes we make art because
we try to be daring so we can't
unfortunately we won't be you know
making the trip once again with with
parks who was
absolute magic in the light of the world
in that movie the late great michael
parks but
i believe in justin long one of my
favorite actors on the planet i've
worked with him many [ __ ] times and
he's not only like
brilliantly funny um and it can ad-lib
three better movies than the one you
write
he he's a horror icon let's be honest
and he can totally pull off what i need
him to do he's going to be able to go
full parks in this
or footballers as we say so um yeah so
it is true kids
i am going to do tusks
banff man is here man and batman was
there for the first time around from
tusk weren't you i was i lived with uh
jason muse in a condo in north carolina
for
six weeks
yes good times man it was good i loved
making that movie man
and i'd taken off three years like i had
quit like directing after
well it was a red state
was the red state no zack and mary right
no zach come here then cop out then read
seriously
i was like i'm retiring and i took three
years off so when tusk happened three
years later coming off of that episode
of smodcast 259 the walrus and the
carpenter
it was this creative burst of like oh
this is [ __ ] fun because it was the
closest experience i ever had to making
clerks again
oddly enough two movies are unrelated in
every other way but they were both made
with the same like mindset which is like
i don't i i did not think about anybody
else if i did i wouldn't have made
[ __ ] tusk because it would have been
like why would you do this um i didn't
think about critics i didn't think about
box office anything about it but i just
wanted to see what it would look like
that's how clerks was born and made and
that's how tusk was born and made at the
same time later years years later so it
was such a wonderfully creative
environment and then add to it we were
making this like madcap [ __ ] batshit
crazy movie that is like essentially an
experimental film you got to remember i
never got to make an experimental film i
made clerks and then suddenly they're
like congratulations you have a career
so i never got to get weird or try
things or be experimental my first movie
like just took off and i'm not bitching
about it that's great but you know it
never
allowed me to [ __ ] around to do some
roger corman [ __ ] or whatever and that's
what tusk felt like to me like all the
fun of
something experimental like knowing that
this doesn't work or this might not work
for everybody and still [ __ ] doing it
for the sake of
you know art just for the sake of being
ballsy just to be like nobody else is
going to make this [ __ ] amanda walrus
movie it better be me so i look forward
to going back man
the
my favorite comment in chat about tusk 2
was
tusks bad to the bone
this
is the title
that was uh dan woods threw that out
there also
for anybody who's [ __ ] on tusk
shot by academy award nominated and emmy
award nominated james laxton
what do you get the emmy award
nomination for uh he was nominated for
uh underground underground railroad with
barry jenkins
um i love laxton uh james laxton uh shot
tusk and he shot yoga hosers with us
and what else one other thing a small
dude
that halloween short film yes that's
right well done jc he shot the uh hollow
ian thing that i did for the holidays
anthology movie horror anthology um yeah
that he grew james lackson grew up to be
an academy award-nominated [ __ ]
world-class dp but what a [ __ ]
beautiful attitude on that guy right
like he was serenity itself like the
[ __ ] buddha
is like working with the butt of this
guy you couldn't rattle him there was no
like you're shooting outside it's hot
you're [ __ ] shooting into lunch it
don't matter he was just like
let's go i'm happy to be here oh
relaxing i love that
what was funny
i bet you'd come back i bet you'd be
like [ __ ] yeah i'll shoot tusks
um because if you look at tusk he's part
of the magic of tusk is a fantastic
looking movie but it has nothing to do
with me i ain't taking the credit for it
[ __ ] that's laxton he's just a
world-class dp guy went on to shoot
[ __ ] moonlight
get nominated for it
he was uh he was funny too because me
and josh roush were doing the behind the
scenes on tusk
and he would not be interviewed he would
not be on camera he like ran away and
hid
and then this past
year i did a ton of like four-year
consideration for underground railroad
and he was on every [ __ ] zoom talking
and crying and
being just like mr self-promotion it was
so funny i was like you know eight years
ago you would not do an interview
so like he's it's funny to watch him now
you know he did he had done like a few
movies before tusk and then he did tusk
and then he did moonlight and now he's
like
he's out there pitching
uh which is he chatting is he chatting
he's not super chatty but he's really
like uh
like thoughtful and and emotional in
what he says
you
you describe laxton to it thoughtful is
definitely one of the first words i
would use to describe him not just as
human being but also as a dp that guy
put a lot of thought into [ __ ] man
always but not like an irritating amount
just he was
like think about it we were making tusks
bro
we weren't making moonlight we were
making tusks and he put his [ __ ] all
into that [ __ ] i'll always appreciate
everyone across the board laxton [ __ ]
the actors they all treated it seriously
everybody acting like we were making
argo and not tusk it was so adorable
i look forward to doing that again
everybody just agree and they're like
look yeah this is stupid yeah it'll
probably suck but let's [ __ ] give it
our all and [ __ ]
yeah i want to show back up and see if
he'll do an in person interview with me
this time
laxman yeah be like i know you talk now
was it just me
i wonder if we'll get him man
that'd be amazing he works a lot and the
only honestly the only reason i don't
think we would get him is because he's
like booked well in advance that's why i
could put in the [ __ ] you know what
i'm going to text
[ __ ] lax lax and be like hey man just
to put this out there in 2024 i really
like to do tusks
let's see if he's like i don't care if
you're doing it in 2030 no
but i think he might i think blackstone
would be like yeah [ __ ] oh my god
let's do it again he was such a sweet
guy tusk is also
part of when i tell like the long
version of the scum and villainy story i
was supposed to be
in tusk
and i didn't i couldn't do it because we
had to push lunch
and i had a phone interview with
lucasfilm that day
i didn't end up getting that job i got
real bitter
and uh
now i own scum and villainy canteen
come on
screw them it's it's kind of like listen
closely it's really a tale of revenge
yeah
um how is the bar
bamf
uh it's good i i thought we were i
thought i was done and that was adorable
you came back in bam
it's good me again here we go
uh
things are really good i started hosting
trivia every wednesday
um fun
i like make up the trivia questions it's
like the geekiest
like the questions aren't like you know
this player on the new york yankees in
1968 it's like
oh that would
but like you get that if you go to any
trivia at any bar in any
place in the country but here it's like
this film released in 1975 was the
uh was the release that coined the term
blockbuster
uh what was the year
1975.
that'd be jaws my friend jaws
so that's the whole i mean it's really
fun what do i win
uh if you can answer 59 more of them uh
what did we do we gave away tickets to
john williams and uh bar credit which
probably wouldn't go very far with you
you'd be like what uh what am i gonna
buy here
what i remember when we used to do the
edumacation pub quiz at uh scum and
villain it was so fun
i i like quit i i don't know what i like
better being the quiz master or actually
[ __ ] answering questions i got very
excited that i knew the answer that
i was like do another one
somebody
yeah [ __ ] the news let's just do trivia
i was i was reading it to jen and josh
who owns the bar with me and he was like
i was like ragging him i'm like how do
you not know this he goes this is all
worthless knowledge i was like josh we
earn off of my worthless knowledge every
week
like it's only worthless right up until
the point that it gets people into the
bar and then it's very valuable
um speaking of john williams at the bowl
we also have a pair of tickets to this
sunday's performance that's right
with the movies
what is it's my show of the movies and
it's john williams music or is he going
to be there himself um i believe he's
going to be there himself there's
there's but so many places you can now
see the 90 year old john williams
conducting an orchestra what day is this
and why are we giving these tickets away
and not going ourselves uh well it's
sunday and apparently you're leaving on
a tour
sunday that's the first day of the
convenience tour clerks 3. see it with
me in a theater near you in a city near
you clerks 3. movie for tickets indeed
so um if you are in if you're in the
chat now if you're in the youtubes and
you would like to potentially win one of
these tickets
have jc pick your question tonight oh is
that it that's how they're going to win
so they're going to win so say when when
you put in your question for the q a say
hi my name is josh from la
because it's got to be a local unless
it's a person who wants to fly into la
for the weekend
and uh and kevin and i will decide which
question deserves the magic tickets he
ain't kidding kids he just told you the
[ __ ] wait you need me to co-sign it
trust everything he says listen to him
too
somebody just said jc i will sleep with
you give me the ticket
i don't think that's a good idea and
it's said no juan eva looks like a girl
or at least somebody who's portraying
themselves as a girl in chat at this
point if it was a boy it would probably
go over better in my life with my family
i could try to talk my way out of that
i was young i was in love
i uh i have a comic book coming out very
soon what'd it say september 1st yes uh
yeah less than two weeks man masquerade
number one hit stands kids
i read it
mark reddit that's right i gave mark a
copyright it's wonderful i uh thank you
that's happening masquerade number one
it's top of november quick stops number
one comes out and i just started writing
a new [ __ ] thing which i love dude
like i'm gonna send you this did i send
you this script
yes
yes
i'm gonna
issue two of it i like this thing very
much because i ain't seen it yet
yeah yeah me and also me and mark are
having these conversations you're like
what are you talking about we're not
gonna tell you but
speaking of [ __ ] that we can't tell you
about me mark working on another thing
remember mark was like i got an idea
he told me the idea and i was the [ __ ]
out of here we've been working on that
and it's moving along kids yeah yeah it
was the thing that was supposed to win
kevin and oscar
but now it seems like it will win kevin
and
it might win all of the semis there you
go
all the emmys
that's how that's how you win their
memories like
make eye contact
um
we uh i can't wait till we get to tell
people about if it happens but it's
looking
very good it is all signs are are
pointing to the positive a fellowship is
forming kids
fellowship with the blaming
yeah
fellowship of the ring peace as jason
news would say um all right
what do we got man should we get into
the news let's get into the news but
before we do that let's do one more ad
oh whoo who who this little al asked the
good folks from emmy
let me tell you something i'm gonna say
this simply give me emmy that's it
[ __ ] i'm all about this emmy [ __ ]
kids uh here follow along go to emmy
eats i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s
dot com slash fat man or just click the
link somewhere below and use the code
fat man you get five bucks off a variety
pack today man uh emmy
is plant-based
ramen noodles man and it is delicious
um meaning it's delicious and i want to
[ __ ] kiss it
uh it's good i didn't they weren't even
a [ __ ] sponsor and i tried them look
i'm a vegan
doesn't make me better than anybody just
means i'm trying not to [ __ ] die
because not being a vegan almost killed
me so get off my dick about it
it's not trendy i'm not hippie i'm
trying to save my life in any event
because of that whenever i go into a
food store i look for all vegan products
and [ __ ] and i saw emmy before they were
even a sponsor i was like oh [ __ ]
vegan ramen i'm gonna try this [ __ ] out
and my god it was so fantastic
um
it it is it's
you can make a bowl
that's
that's so
goddamn yummy
um and it's vegan as [ __ ] man even the
noodles it's [ __ ] it's low carb it's
only 6 grams of net carbs per serving uh
high [ __ ] protein that's what we
plant people like 21 grams of protein
each serving of emmy helps you stay full
longer man it's 100 plant-based uh and
dairy-free good for digestive health if
you've got problems with the shits
emmy's for you man 18 grams of fiber
it's gonna push that [ __ ] [ __ ] right
out you right uche into the toilet man
it's four times as much fiber than other
instant ramen brands also lower in
sodium convenient as [ __ ] you make it
seven minutes [ __ ] done they got
spicy beef ramen tom yum shrimp ramen
black garlic chicken ramen and there's
none of those things it's not beef it's
not shrimp
they put those
a lot of quotes because it's vegan high
quality ingredients man they use high
quality ingredients for the noodle and
soup base with no unnatural
preservatives
many of the customers have said they
felt very sluggish and tired after
eating traditional instant ramen with
emmy they feel productive and they're in
a better head space i agree with that i
don't even think that's hype man they
use better ingredients it's [ __ ]
plant-based it's not like some processed
[ __ ]
um what do you what are you waiting for
try them out for heaven's sakes feel
free kids
click the link below or go to emmyeats
imm
immi eats.com
fat man and use the code fat man check
out man uh you're gonna get five bucks
off your variety pack today try it out
you like ramen and you're like you know
i could do without eating meat and [ __ ]
here's your chance here's your chance to
[ __ ] dance vegan style kids
if you don't like one vegan you're like
[ __ ] vegans great just say plant-based
uh we'll say whatever you want but it's
better for you kids try it out man at
emmyeats.com
fat man and we thank the good folks at
emmy eats for not only sponsoring this
show but for making some [ __ ] good
ass ramen
that a uh that a guy with heart problems
can enjoy boom
um okay
news
mr mark bernard is bringing us news i
can't wait to hear what's going on in
the world of culture that pops ladies
and gentlemen mark bernard with the news
look at him saluting
you had a very benny hill thing going on
uh i think we had talked about this when
it was a rumor potentially but now it
seems to be fact that uh that our boy
friend of the show matt shotman
is going to direct the fantastic four i
got very excited when i saw that i was
like we know that guy we actually had
him on this [ __ ] show like
uh how awesome for him look he did a
great job with [ __ ] one division man
of course give him fantastic four he had
to drop out of a star trek picture to do
it you had to drop out of the star trek
picture to do it and
i mean you know bob's your uncle you
gotta rob peter to pay paul whatever
that is but they're two fantastic things
to have to choose from
that's true that's that's the best of
all possible worlds but he chose wisely
i mean
fantastic four are gonna be [ __ ] huge
you know the fourth trek movie or
marvel's first family and it seems like
he chose marvel's first family
um i like the way you put it
you know i like the way you say [ __ ] i
like to cuddy your gym i like your
pretty mouth um
um in case those who uh who might not
have been here for the match shocking
episode which you should go back and
watch it was very very fun
um but he was he directed one division
which is why he was here talking to us
he also directed a bunch of it's always
sunny in philadelphia as well as game of
thrones
um
but it was one division i think that
that endeared him to the good folks at
marvel and
he's their guy you know it is it is
unclear however who is going to be any
of the members of the fantastic four um
it is a hundred percent uncertain
whether or not john krasinski who played
reed richards in doctor strange did it
um will actually be marvel's pick for it
there's a rumor that uh penn badgley who
i think is on a netflix show called you
um
had been approached by marvel um but
that is only a rumor and nobody knows
nothing about
mark you know
andrew lawless which i can't imagine
that's his real name in chat
um is feels bad for you he says my heart
breaks for mark with all his fantastic
ideas
to have to listen to a tusk's
pitch
was it hard to sit through does that
thesis track at all or is this dude just
being an [ __ ] for the sake of being
an [ __ ]
um i think potentially the latter and
not the former
um
not sure if he's an [ __ ] but this is
not how did you wind up with me how did
you wind up in the audience of this show
good sir
around here we keep it very [ __ ]
civil
watch yourself andrew lawless um
unless you're the son of lucy lawless in
which case say hi to your mother
yeah
um what else we got what's the next
piece of news um
ben kingsley
and
trevor is going to be returning to the
marvel universe in the wonder man tv
show now he's not playing wonder man
he's playing trevor slattery he's
playing trevor slattery they haven't
announced have they announced that there
was going to be a wonder man tv show
they did indeed um daniel uh
destin credon who had
um
the filmmaker behind shanghai
um it was revealed i think back in like
may or april or may but earlier this
year that he was going to be doing a uh
he's he was the one shepherding the
wonderman tv show
um
and so given that canonically wonder man
is an actor simon williams
um the the sound of a wealthy
industrialist um losing out his company
losing out to tony stark's stark
industries he then goes to work for
baron zero and then one point he had
been
in the west coast avengers a performer
um and so it would make some sense
for uh marvel's finest actor to join up
with simon williams for shenanigans
uh
i'm ready
i like him i like trevor trevor slattery
travis lottery i liked him uh much more
in iron man
than i did in uh
in um
what was in shanghai
yeah um
but uh i i like that they brought it
back and they keep i got to plug my [ __ ]
in that they bring it back and that
they're going to keep them going man
especially
since
wonder man is so
hollywood-based or you know that makes
acting based
yeah i mean at one point i think it was
in guardians 2
um there were posters um up on the wall
of a movie theater in one of the
flashbacks
um
that revealed that there had been a
simon williams
movie in theaters
um with at that point nathan fillion
playing simon williams
unclear if that casting will continue
um
but it is a lovely little bit
the rookie himself the rookie himself
uh i have to imagine it would be
difficult to uh to split his time
between
la's finest
and marvel
but uh maybe not
they're both owned by disney it's one
big happy family
i'm in
you're ready what else you got you know
what else i meant for uh the fourth
season upcoming of harley wait wait wait
what could henry cavill be [ __ ] uh
wonder man i mean there was a rumor that
he was meeting with marvel to talk about
potentially during the mcu he's got the
look man you put the glasses on him and
the [ __ ]
wow yeah
he looks good perhaps in the safari
jacket or whatever it was that that
wonder man used to wear
um what was he only cut a dashing figure
that's simon williams
and cavill does an outstanding american
accent
um what else we got harley quinn season
four is happening
um
despite the fact that hbo max seems to
have been on a decimation tear as of
late um this is one that is going to
come back out of the gate even before
season three drops on september 15th
there's gonna be a season four
uh i love this cartoon uh and at the
same time i'm so jealous of it
i really feel like a failure of anyone
in this world i should have been like oh
let's do a batman that curses and it
never once occurred to me
reverence for the character i was like
he would never
talk about eating
[ __ ] he [ __ ] bats though apparently he
does [ __ ] geez um so i'm happy for
those kids man it is quality program and
funny and [ __ ] well-written they know
their [ __ ] history their dc history
um
so good for them yeah wow one of the few
things that's uh going forward at hbo
yes the the rare light of good news out
of at least for nerds out of the hbo max
warner brothers discovery camp
um
especially given that another news story
is there is no dc fandom
this fall
is this also a [ __ ]
victim of the cuts or something it's
less a victim of the cuts and more a
the fandom began it grew as a way to
connect fans to their nerd quality i
mean quality content during the pandemic
when we could not go to conventions dc
lost a virtual convention right now that
we can go back
they were like well
now that we're doing it again now that
we just did san diego now that we're
about to do new york comic con now that
you know covet has been beaten back at
least to the place where it's no longer
you know unimaginable to gather in
numbers
it's like we don't need to do a virtual
convention anymore we're just doing real
ones
um tracks and tracks you know that was
their statement with the return of
in-person events warner brothers
discoveries excited to be able to engage
with our fans live at numerous comic
cons around the world and will not be
scheduling dc fandom for 2022.
geez
yeah
in chat kabuki kid asked a question he
said did you ask neil gaiman if you
could write the fun land character can
you elaborate on that experience
true when i did the batman
series uh with walter the widening gyre
um
one of the sequences had batman
saving a child at a
seaside gotham amusement park
um kind of like santa monica pier or
something
and um the person who had the kid was
fun land which was the serial killer
from
um
you know uh neil gaines the sandman from
the jew with john d which they recently
did
depicted in the real world
so when i was writing batman i was like
well i mean [ __ ]
he's got somebody grabbed a kid so
[ __ ] i'll go with fun land and [ __ ]
and uh no there was no process to answer
the question i didn't have to ask neil
i'm sure i doubt neil knew about it and
stuff um if he did i'm sure he would
have been more like oh that's adorable
rather than like give me money or
something
um but yeah no i i i remember just being
like hey like in the script i wrote to
walter because he was the artist like
use fun land from from uh the sandman
and uh that's how he wound up in the
book i thought of that recently when i
was watching the sandman when that
episode happened i was like oh [ __ ] i
put
him in the back and booked that one time
anyway back to the news back to the news
um
here is a i'm not even going to call
this an odd story or even a weird story
um
it's
curious in the best way
will eisner's a contract with god
um
is
is is thought of it's it's referred to
as the very first graphic novel um 1978
will eisner who is you know one of the
great pillars of comic book
creation
this book is being developed as a stage
musical
the will eisner follies the wills and
follies um
you know i mean the the book it's it's
very much consists of four interweaving
stories
revolving around the lives of uh buried
new yorkers living in a fictional parent
house you know most of those new yorkers
or many of them are jewish and maybe
they're immigrants and like
if it's all in the same location and
it's all a bunch of different stories
which kind of connect with each other
i see a version of that completely being
able to exist on on stage
the music is being written
by sam hollander
lisa loeb mares yahoo ryan miller and
jill sobel
and the producer is a fellow named vivek
tawar
who did the jagged little pill and
american idiot
on broadway and has won tony's for all
that work and it's like oh all right you
know
wait who
vivek tawari
i know him you know him very well vivek
vivek is doing this yeah
right the [ __ ] on man well that makes
sense he's a big comic book guy he's a
huge kind of guy he wrote a book called
the fifth beatle yeah
you know the the dude who did not make
the cut
um
and so like
you know yeah
like at first it's like that's gonna be
a musical and then you start reading the
things and then you're like you know
what all right
[ __ ] it
he's smart in the vague he's got he's
he's a smart guy man he put together
some cool stuff we're working on a thing
i'll just do that right there indeed
um so yeah i'm uh i'm curious yeah me
too especially now knowing vivek's
involved
yeah
i mean there's a great quote from him
saying you know
for me a contract with god was a
formative grounds here for all my
creative work
um like will i was born in new york city
a child of immigrants who grew up
surrounded by immigrant dreams both
beautiful and frustrating a contract
with god helped me understand both new
york city and myself i'm thrilled now to
work alongside this group of top-notch
inspiring jewish musicians to bring a
stage production of contract with god to
both fans of the graphic novel and to
inspire new audiences
boom hey man look at that [ __ ]
a man so good at his art form that he
he's the musical the man is the musical
um i got a drawing an original drawing
from uh eisner in the uh
secret stash he drew hear it for me and
he's going hi kevin
um
i met once like 20 years ago at this
point
when i was an eisner judge and he was
still with us
and he would always like hang around
backstage with the eisners and he would
you know not quite be the emcee but he
would always be there chairman emeritus
chairman emeritus and so i was i was
presenting in eisner
and so i got to meet him backstage very
quickly you know and i was a bit nervous
because at that point in my life i had
not done much stage work
and so it was like don't want a kid
they're comics people they'll laugh
and so i went out and told one dumb joke
and they laughed and he was right
because he's realized
he knew he knew sweet guy was very nice
to me too
yeah
um
here here's a weird one
apparently
thanos
thomas
has blossomed into a popular baby name
are you [ __ ] me in a new study
published by organic baby formula thanos
has risen 2 892 spots in the social
security administration name popularity
index since adventures infinity war was
released four years ago
it is now the ninth most popular baby
name based on disney-owned characters
that's a very specific list let's hear
that let's hear that list
quill after guardians of the galaxies
peter quill is number one
people are naming their kids quill yeah
uh kristoff
from frozen
rey
clearly aladdin getting a lot of pull
but i'm not sure if that's because it is
new because it's aladdin
merida from brave
bell again doesn't have to be disney
cinema
sure
and olaf
and then after that
is thanos
people are naming their [ __ ] kids
olaf like
that little snowman
yeah
wow
no judgment i named a kid harley quinn
so
but wow
wow bam see ya what's up f man what you
got no anakin on that list i know crazy
right isn't that nuts it's on the list
but it's lower on the list
people are new
the thanos thing that boggles my mind
have they seen the picture
i i have so many things
comments about the complex
that kid comes the kid gets to be a
certain age sees that movie is just like
is that my destiny
yes
yeah get to get to work
kids snapping sorry champ
who
is more famous
for snapping in the comic book universe
thanos
or snapper car
snapper card did it all the time like he
was obsessive-compulsive thanos just did
it once right and then tried to do it
twice and then it didn't happen
okay so after thanos on this list in
popularity
timon
nala
kylo
anakin moana
flynn
from tangled
lair
wanda
valkyrie
what
those lay and wand are shockingly low on
the list they really are now
it's
this i think is also charting
the increase in popularity
so it's entirely popular or possible
that leia has just always been poppy
that the increase in popularity of leia
has remained steady
this is just the growth
in the last couple of years any baby
yodain on that list no kids named krogu
they know so far
um tiana elsa cinderella naveen
esmeralda ariel sebastian loki
uh aurora luke finn and jasmine
bamf
what about what about
no chewie's on that list no choose them
well you know it's that's a very
specific name what do you got to say for
yourself bam man i was just going to say
there's an incredible opportunity here
with tusk 2
to have justin long have a baby that's
named walrus man
which was the
character and we could try to get walrus
man up on that list
good [ __ ] point that's right man
again a list that we're not really a
part of
um
who charts and tracks
this
like children named after disney kids
what a weird job indeed i mean you know
the social security agency
you know registers every name so that
they can begin you know at some point
collecting monies to pay that person
back later on in their dotage
but who who grinds through that data to
look for pop culture names i'm not sure
but i thank them for their service
james b and chad says nine num would be
a brilliant name i agree how come nine
nums not on that list
this is my [ __ ] son nine numb
and he's like oh
he talks just like them
people like what are you [ __ ] is he
speaking in tongues like no he's talking
nine num man whatever that [ __ ]
language is yeah because one dude did it
once and that kid got the [ __ ] kicked
out of him and nobody ever did it
not enough you got a lot of places to go
you call him nnn
i mean nine automatically sounds german
and negative
and wasn't there a star trek like seven
and nine or something
i mean seven is a better name yeah seven
that was about star galactica right
um he was six
yes not by one off by one
uh what else we got um our last story of
the evening is uh is is is a fitting one
that
um there is going to be uh
at some point relatively soon
um something that they're calling the
enterprise mission
um as part of the united launch
alliance's um vulcan centaur mission to
deliver a lunar lander to the moon
um and part of this mission they're not
saying entirely when it's going to be
um
the ashes of actors michelle nichols
james doing major bear rottenberry and
star trek tv series creator gene
roddenberry
will be
flown into space
that's pretty magical right there
yeah um
good for them and then on the same
mission i don't look before we go
further i don't know much about space
mark but i do know this space
is the final frontier
and it seems that these people who are
part of the ongoing missions into
chronicling the voyages of the final
frontier um would be this would be a
fitting resting place for that
absolutely
um hitchhiking along with them will be
uh ashes of
douglas trumbull visual effects whiz
um an oscar winner will also be
uh
jettisoned
ceremoniously into outer space i applaud
this
however the young catholic in me
was told that in the end days
our bodies will be raised from the grave
and joined with our souls
how are they going to find these bodies
floating around in space
well i i have to imagine that there's a
better gps for bodies and souls than
just gravestones
i'd have to think
i thought that's what gravestones were
all about so on the last day the lord
could be like okay alphabetically andrew
[Laughter]
get up rise and join your soul
uh that's really beautiful is there any
any way you would like to anything you
want done with your carcass or your
ashes um fetish a death fetish where
you're like yeah yeah
we're into a lady's [ __ ] shoes
drag me behind the
evangeline's hot pink corvette
as she crusts until age 193
still the cruise in a sense extra um not
especially i'm not overwhelmingly
fixated on what happens to me after
death i would just like to not die
that'd be cool if we work that out um
i'd like to be half gatling for a bit
uh look i'm all for eternal life don't
get me wrong
but
here's what i want
passes on in case i forget to put it in
a will or mention it to a loved one or
something like that all right like i'll
be the dude who like does anybody have
anything else to say before we deal with
this
kev told me and jen's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about no he told me on a
podcast here's what he wanted like you
could be like let's go to the videotape
and they could pull this right up right
now
um
i always wanted to put uh
life-size bronze statues
of jay and silent bob in front of
quickstop
which i think that building will be
there long after me
put those bronze statues and in them put
put in the silent bob put my ashes
um could we not just mummify you
and then build the brass statues around
it
i'll tell you you're now you're thinking
now you're thinking like a salesman
because [ __ ] a statue somebody's like
what he mummified himself to sell
tickets after death that [ __ ]
money-grubbing piece of [ __ ] i gotta go
and then they're gonna come see
that mini leaning on the wall like this
like
yeah you know like it's some [ __ ]
reliquary it's a lot of [ __ ]
they pulled my brain out through my nose
to do this in the old traditional way i
mean if you want it that way we can
totally honor those wishes but what
about on the last day when our bodies
are reunited with our souls don't i want
my brain to be involved
listen i'm just the mummification ritual
happened way before the bodies being
reunited by your souls
um
oh look at you pulling rank on jesus
i'm just saying
three thousand get some guys we're gonna
get us cancelled talking [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that like the egyptians predate
jesus
or you want if you're a mother well yeah
it was year one and there's a whole like
3000 bc before that like
uh literally it says bc that means
before that guy
not in my world in my world bc means
before clerks and then a d means after
dante those are the two eras of my life
how things changed incredibly thank you
it's a very short window but i like it
very tiny window um
what uh
is that all the news that's fits
apparent that's all the news is fit to
print my friend um this is a not a news
thing but did you see the
uh was it mike diodato jr was like
nemours not built enough and he put up a
picture of himself like in his
muscly back and [ __ ]
i would never take my shirt off in
public like
that i don't have that body if i had his
body i would man
but like that was
that was a weird story where suddenly
you had a comic book artist
telling an actor like who are saying
this actor is not nearly as in shape as
i am it's like
what would they say last year
i didn't have that on my bingo car
yeah it's it's it's weird
all i got out of that story was that
dude's jacked
with this [ __ ]
like he's 60 or something and he was
jacked in the photo jet and body shaming
a man half of his age
for representing a culture that may not
give a [ __ ] about
being cut and shredded
is that
i mean it's entirely possible that
atlanteans
don't give a [ __ ] like
most people
even in great shape are not built like
the rock
and and throughout eternity
the amount of time in which people look
like that is relatively narrow
because deprivation was never a status
symbol
you [ __ ] give me more of this you're
making me feel good about not being
ripped
i mean because i mean [ __ ] if you if
you look back at like sean connery at
one point was like a mr universe
and that dude was never ripped like that
because
gave a [ __ ] about bodies it looked like
mr atlas all those things from from the
back of comic books you know kicking
saying the guy who made a man out of mac
like
they were not nearly as as ridiculous
looking as and i say ridiculous in
quotes um
as as sort of modern bodybuilders and
modern actors and modern people who 100
work their bodies to within an inch of
tolerances but look that way
strength did not require that level of
deprivation
um
people could just be [ __ ] huge you
look at the the you look at the
strongest men in the world magnus for
magnuson dudes that are like pulling
mack trucks and [ __ ] launching logs into
the air they are huge they gotta play
the the [ __ ] mountain and game of
thrones was one of those guys and he's
just massive
you know does the dude playing neymar
need to be
[ __ ] the rock could be sure does he
have to be no and that feels like it's a
choice
and one that i can give her
bathman's here before he joins us i'm
gonna shout out and chat false flags had
one of the deepest cut references i've
ever seen
in my life
it says because he's out of shape which
is literally ernie o'donnell's line as
the trainer
clerks
well done my friend
deepest of deep cuts over to banff man
what do you have i'm just gonna like if
you watch the olympics like michael
phelps the greatest swimmer of all time
is is
felt
but he's not
anywhere near the rock or even like
what hugh jackman looked like as
wolverine
so if a guy is
swims
he wouldn't be
huge and beefy he'd be svelte
i think that i think there's the uh
justification he's got a swimmer's body
yeah
those dudes are lean but they're not
insane because they have to have so many
[ __ ] calories to do the work they do
that they're not about me i mean i
remember reading like yeah michael
phelps will eat 12 000 calories a day
if he's in olympics like if he's
performing he's competing
because he needs that much [ __ ]
energy to make it all go
well like
it's a lot i had a friend who was he's
12 000 calories just because
i had a friend who was um who was hugh
jackman's personal chef
um for for a good year or so back when
he was in manhattan
doing um i can't remember the name of
the play
it wasn't it wasn't music man yet but i
think it was the it was the previous
musical he was in on broadway
um
and uh he was training for a wolverine
thing
and he used to wake himself up at like
three o'clock in the morning to eat a
whole [ __ ] steamed chicken
and a pint of brown rice because his
body just needed to add that much
protein to be able to build that much
muscle
like it was an awful
experience to have to get into that kind
of shape
then most people just living a life
don't do that
you don't have to sell me i'm not
getting into shape like that
i'm nowhere close that seems like a lot
of work
you know like working out three times a
day eating every three hours because
your body just needs to have that
protein to add that muscle that just
reminds me of wally west man i remember
when i started reading the flash
he was talking about like i've got to
eat pizzas just to [ __ ] wake up and i
was like oh that tracks that makes sense
like he would have to his body would be
burning [ __ ]
calories no matter what he did
i like when comics makes sense
especially comics about
boys who solve their problems by running
really fast
um so yes that that is all of the news
um i am impressed by mike diaz physique
as an old man but yeah i was too very
impressed but adding you know applying
modern contemporary
um
uh stateside morals and
and workout ethics to a fictional
underwater
sovereign um maybe it's about apple's
knowledge
um here's my hot take i can't wait to
see what they do with nemour
yeah
like
that's i can't believe we're seeing
nemour in the movie now this is nuts and
he's got wings on his feet just like in
the comics
um all right there it was because
there's all the news
you're never getting any more news
tonight because the news happened ladies
and gentlemen
uh thank mr mark bernard for bringing in
the news
next part about uh somebody asked in
chat they talk about samaritan i did not
see that yet that's the stallone
superhero movie right indeed that's on
amazon prime it's on amazon prime so i
guess maybe we'll get to that next week
or something um
uh all right that's it this is the only
thing we seem to have missed
a lot of people are saying is it nemour
or neymar
i i've always pronounced it name or but
uh
but i think that's fine we can let
neymar himself correct us if one of us
is right one of us is wrong we're going
to hear it in the movie i always
pronounce it submariner
as did i
submarine not submariner who would ever
call him that because he's not in the
submarine he's below the marin
that's right
he's way below that marin
um dr nitrogen's musical empire says
samaritan was great all right so i'm
gonna [ __ ] check it out all right
we'll get into it
um
well yes until then
here what's up man
potato potato are you adat or atat
to death [ __ ]
oh i'll i'll [ __ ] fight you if you
say 18. what the [ __ ] adat all the way
mark hamill said we just called them
walkers
which i thought was so [ __ ] cool i
was like oh my god like of course he
would talk about them as well
yeah
they do refer to them it's like imperial
walkers
i never called them imperial i called
them like as a kid i called them snow
walkers until they
put out the kenner put out the ad at and
then it was adapt for the rest of my
life because in the commercial they call
it an ad app
in the toy commercial they say ada they
say adad in the toy commercial so we're
right
i think we are right they told us how to
stay
and also if i remember correctly there
are no periods between the a and the t
correct
right so it's like all right i feel like
i'm justified
and also it's shorter
i don't take all day to say atat
but i will say a-t-e-s-t
i ate to the game
wrote when the sea living guy punches
you in the eye that's nemouri
[Music]
outstanding another another one from the
kids in paul ladies and gentlemen
endless music says smith slams adapt
pronunciation
um all right so do we uh we're about to
get into the q a do we have one more
sponsor for the evening was it we do
were throwing us money apparently show
so expensive kids that we require three
[ __ ] sponsors man this is like shogun
as a mini series
huge bigger in life so it requires three
sponsors our final sponsor for the
evening kids
uh good folks that we absolutely love
they've come to us time and time again
uh and told us hey
uh do your
magic uh
tell the people the good people about
what we have to offer it's not hard and
it certainly will be
after they get their mouths all around a
blue chew ladies and gentlemen that's
right the good folks at blue chew
are another sponsor tonight man follow
along as we talk about blue chew they
got a special deal for our listeners try
blue chew free
when you use the promo code fat man all
one word f-a-t-m-a-n at checkout just
pay five dollars ship and you can get
free
bluetooth that's bluetooth.com promo
code fatman to receive your first month
free [ __ ]
free for nothing foc free of charge um
the uh uh
visit luchu.com right now why aren't you
doing it for more details and important
safety information we thank the good
folks of blue chew for sponsoring the
podcast um guys
it's time to bring that summer heat into
the bedroom we've said it before or
pictures aren't the only thing that
that's rising this summer
that's right man this episode is
sponsored by blue chew kids guys
confidence can take you far in life it
can also help you
in the boudoir
especially
yeah the one chicago room especially
when it comes time to step up to the
plate
that i believe is reference to the act
of copulation having sex kids that is
blue chew comes in blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost it
just makes [ __ ] sense kids
you can take them any time day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises
see what i'm saying the process is
simple you sign up at bluechew.com you
consult with one of their licensed
medical professionals uh providers and
once you're approved you will receive
your prescription within days man then
you [ __ ] pop that [ __ ] in your mouth
like popeye no no no no
[Music]
that's how it works is that amazing man
blue chews tablets are made right here
in the usa they're prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a very discreet
package so your mailman's like like hey
you're chewing the blue i see
i guess you need some of that pop eye on
your dick
[Music]
and you're both doing at each other
right there at the front door
your wife's like honey are you doing the
popeye theme song with [ __ ] boss man
yes because we're both blue chewers
be a blue chewer [ __ ] what are
you waiting for try it out [ __ ] it free
don't cost nothing once again try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code fat man all one word at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping you
ain't gonna get a better deal today
yes that's bluechew.com promo code
fatman to receive your first month free
visit bluechew.com for more detail more
details and important safety information
as well don't forget
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
ear podcast
boom
thank you
you're the best
um all right hit me
hit me jc
bam
please hammer don't hurt him hit me jc
we had a bunch of really good questions
so i think do we do two
non-la questions and then i have like
three la questions and we can answer our
favorite one
and send the tickets to that person i
got time for three because i'm uh
packing up a card
cross country we'll do
two questions and then the last question
we'll we'll answer one of three we'll
pick our favorite of the three we'll put
it out there yeah
move it all right so my
uh first question i really liked this
because i was watching winnie the pooh
with jocelyn today oh
look at you man don't use your kids
excuse for watching who you were
watching winnie the pooh
i was watching it was a weird 1988 one
though so i
it was strange was pooh like [ __ ]
singing hip-hop what was what was modern
about it was like a
really upbeat theme song
winnie the poochee
yo what up mr robin winnie winnie the
poochie went home to his planet i have
to go now to my home planet
well anyway back to when uh so grassy
hill wanted to know
uh would you rather be a superhero or
christopher robin on one hand you get
hold on deep cuts joke kabuki kid wrote
winnie the pooh and tyler knew took 182.
kids
if you never saw turk182 you're not
missing anything but you're going to
miss a lot of deep cuts jokes like that
that makes marx look at that mark laughs
at a turk 182 i love that it's like the
secret key to mirth on this podcast
it's like if you want to know how to get
to these guys heart go home watch
terp182
johnny disco said winnie the blue chew
[ __ ] we need these guys doing the ads
i'm ready christopher robin
speaking a witch did you see the [ __ ]
winnie the pooh blood and honey trailer
it did i love that winnie the pooh is in
the public domain and so anybody could
do anything to winnie the pooh and they
did they certainly did but it looked
well shot as i looked at it like i was
like it looks better than anything i
ever shot and [ __ ] i look forward to
watching it
i'll be honest with you i know some
people like this is a [ __ ] atrocity
to
the legend of winnie the pooh the tale
of winnie the pooh but i'm like
satire mad magazine i liked mad magazine
when i was a kid so sue me
that's about philip seymour hoffman and
[ __ ]
talented mr ripley when he's on the
piano
and i thought that was your philip
seymour hoffman in uh boogie nights
awesome
where he's like
he's chewing on the pen
now here's my philip seymour hoffman
do you got a girlfriend
a wife i'm gonna find her
i'm gonna find her i'm gonna hurt her
i got a car you want to see my new car
um all right what was the question jason
okay good question
uh would you rather be a superhero or
christopher robin
one hand you get super powers
uh on the other all of your childhood
toys are your real life friends
100 christopher robin man
100
all my childhood toys come to life and
they're my buddies
so there
could you imagine the [ __ ] they would
say we watched you pull your winky
what's that about like well [ __ ]
i guess
don't you know what masturbation is
they're like show us and it turns out
all my toys are dirty little cucks
odd
it's hot man
like we like to watch kev
that's a big hair reference um
yeah yeah christopher robbins man that
was it christopher robin or robin's was
he plural or singular
christopher robin one one just
not one robin not two yeah i mean if
there's more than one person there then
they could be christopher robins or if
it's possessive that's the [ __ ]
winnie the pooh i want to [ __ ] watch
where there's two christopher robins and
poo is like which one do i choose obama
and he's like poo it's me i'm the real
one don't you remember and then the
other one's like don't listen to him boo
i'm the real one and pooh's like my head
and he's like i'll just kill them both
yes i love the idea of two people
killing each other for the love of the
doll no that was poo killing both of
them oh who kills them
thing now that's trendy who was a killer
killer i mean his brain is stuffed with
fluff you can't expect very much yeah he
gets off that's how he gets off he's
like he's not responsible for his action
he's a tubby little cubby all stuff with
fluff so
your honor
you have to let him go
i've only got the one synapse and it
likes pain
i wouldn't say that likes pain he just
doesn't understand the difference
between pain and pleasure they're all
the same sensation to him it's like my
dog i we got tile in the house we got
tile outside the house and everyone gets
weirded out when she shits in the house
i'm like
she
everywhere she shits it's tile
she don't make a difference she's not
like oh this is on the one side of the
door for reasons it's like this is a
tile
you tell me [ __ ] on tile out there
what's the difference it's in the
[ __ ] house
what do you want from me i got a lot of
understanding for my little doctor mark
i mean the empathy abounds
thank you thank you that's what i was
looking for empathy i was sitting there
going like what's the word
but empathy is much more political
um all right what about you i go [ __ ]
superhero all day long
mostly because
christopher robin is still just gonna be
that [ __ ] dude
you know and his toys get to come alive
and tell him things
but that doesn't seem as helpful as i
don't know
being wolverine
or
seems like a lot of work though you got
to work out you can't skip leg day you
got to wake up and eat chicken and rice
well i would be huge
i
you want to be the one where they give
you the weapon x body so you don't even
have to
just wake up in your [ __ ] thor like
that would be right
which thor
um
thor jack thor or fat thor
or vincent d'onofrio thor
adventures in babysitting
ooh
that's another that's another thor we
hadn't thought about another deep
thorough cut um
yeah i don't know i guess
i guess i feel like playtime would wear
itself out relatively quickly
um but being a
non-immortal incredibly invulnerable
person who can fly through the heavens
would be just as cool if not cooler
that's just me
he's right kids don't be christopher
robin
be a superhero you can help others all i
think about is helping myself and those
my childhood choice coming to life helps
me in some weird way probably wouldn't
they'd probably be like kill kill kill
and i'm like oh my god why didn't i
choose superhero i'm such a dick but
mark did choose superhero he saves me
from those killer toys
i mean i would save you because you're
my friend and i would do that
but if i didn't know i'm not saying i
would be like a
right wrong or do-gooder
that would just have the powers of a god
oh that that just seems like more fun
hey hey
hey
you have the powers of a god right now
writer
[Music]
don't you [ __ ] forget it son
writers are kings
here we are
we're the princes of the universe
grips
putting in lots of periods it's getting
overpaid to make up stupid [ __ ]
to be kings princess of the universe
um all right give us another question
okay
andrew chambers had a question uh just
like the star wars galactic star cruiser
hotel
which movie or tv show would you want an
immersive hotel experience of
greg
from sydney australia so he's
in tomorrow
uh you go first i gotta answer some a
question over here
um
i feel
oh [ __ ] you know what would be kind of
dope
i i [ __ ] i'm torn i'm torn between
wanting a princess bride
[ __ ] um immersive hotel slash space
whatever you know and i'm hoping that
it's man by people and not robots
because westworld is always waiting on
the other side of this
um
i feel like that would be kind of dope
or
um
i'm i'm i'm stuck between tron
and the matrix and specifically the
[ __ ] matrix of the the weird ass sex
rave
of matrix um reloading
i think there's some there's some fun to
be here i think you know it's [ __ ] if
you're a single dude and you just want
to get down with a bunch of hot sweaty
people and have a slightly overweight
morpheus tell you what to do
i'm here for that as well
so yeah sweat rave oh but then there's
[ __ ] blade and you get to go to the
bloodbath
the [ __ ] underground nightclub with a
bunch of vampires and bloods coming from
the ceiling that is super [ __ ] dope
too
that's me doing that scene
um
so yeah i had too many i didn't narrow
it down at all i'm sorry
it can't be star wars anything but star
wars
oh
wayne manor wayne manor
full access
so up top it's like a posh hotel like
[ __ ] old-timey [ __ ]
high-end expensive fairmont kind of
hotel
but
part of your stay is that you know just
like in star wars you're in on the
action and [ __ ]
you're in on the action here man so you
get to go into the bat cave as well and
there's a [ __ ] mission
where you know how like in star trek uh
star wars uh that you leave the cruise
and you go one on one of the rides and
stuff
um
this there's like a adventure involving
the [ __ ] joker
and riddler
and cat woman and [ __ ] kite man
for no good reason because because you
could fly somebody inside and [ __ ] right
just like on wires like it's not a lot
totally um oh my god the wayne manor
[ __ ] getaway
you got my money take all my money and
then you get to go down to the batcave
and you know how you get there right
calls
what polls
you're doing the little [ __ ] the
firemen poll
well yeah i guess i'm at the clock you
gotta go through the grandfather clock
right you gotta set the time that your
parents died and then the clock opens
and then you gotta do a long spiral
staircase in the back head that's how
they do it in the comics that pull [ __ ]
i mean i'd much rather lift beethoven's
head and just press a button and then
just oh would i so we should make
options for people
well there's also many lines so we could
have the
60s entrance effect the adam west
entrance
the comics authentic entrance
bat batmobile's down there you get to
sit in it [ __ ]
is there also a tunnel that leads you to
arkansas
there is now you genius
oh my god
you can and you can just do the hallway
and it's just like the rooms like and
you get to see in and it's just actors
and outfits and [ __ ] and they're just
like
mister's ass cutting his [ __ ] skin
and [ __ ] like that penguin like wow
he's like what am i doing in arkham i'm
not crazy i'm just a gangster
i mean is there one that you could do
that's that's that is just arkham asylum
but it's like that sleep no more
um
[ __ ] the macbeth immersive theater
thing that they used to put on i think
they put on in new york in brooklyn they
had a big warehouse thing where you
would like literally go from floor to
floor to floor
and just walk through this kind of you
know evolving drama
but it was just arkham asylum and you're
there you know as in the middle of a
[ __ ] breakout you're there in the
middle of an alan moore story
about the art the night at arkham
yes
uh i'm i'm buying tickets to this right
now
in the corner there's [ __ ] killer
croc
i hear they're making it right now as we
speak more oh no no
it was just killed like hbo max shows
because there has to be another naked
and afraid
we'll spend our money there
um yeah man build the batman [ __ ]
wayne manor resort
with the kung fu grip i'll go
yeah
[ __ ] i buy one um that was a great
question all right bam man what you got
you got an answer for that man
i was gonna say uh labyrinth
we were talking about jennifer conley
earlier
look i'd go but [ __ ] that place would
close in a year because most kids are
like what's labyrinth
um
joel rolston in chat had the best the
clue mansion
i wouldn't say that's the best
but a pretty strong contender it would
be the most like
you know in universe
yeah and you get to do you could do like
a mystery like dinner mystery theater
kind of thing and you could also make it
an escape room kind of affair it'd be
much bigger
than the galactic star cruiser
it would be cheaper than the wayne manor
and the bat cave and [ __ ] but not better
it would not be necessarily better
uh all right what's the next one okay
we're picking these are all people from
the los angeles area vying for
uh john williams tickets so we have a
question about if you could live in a
sitcom we have a question about
uh
do you have a movie that makes you so
emotional you can
barely watch it
or a she-hulk
west coast avengers question where do we
want to go
what were the what was the first one
uh
[Music]
live in a sitcom
second one
a movie that you love but you can't
really watch because it's too emotional
and then the last one is she-hulk west
coast avengers
i guess the
first one
for me what about you mark i was gonna
go number two the movie that that'll
make you so emotional you can't watch it
um i don't i absolutely have no answer
for that but do you have one
um
i i do but if we think about a system we
want to live in we could also do that
that's cool
let's do that uh this is laura mays from
orange county
if you could live in a sitcom past or
present for a week what would it be and
why
good times
really
i was one of my favorite sitcoms of all
time i watched every episode of good
times i saw it multiple [ __ ] times
um james senior
good great dad
i would like to be i don't want to be
bookman
um i'd like to be like a penny
i'd like to be the white male penny
gets to come in for episodes and [ __ ]
like that not every episode but like
when you show up people love you
um you know i know that it's [ __ ]
jj's show so i'm not trying to steal a
spotlight i'm a fan i don't want stupid
spotlight i love them all
thelma [ __ ] malona [ __ ]
michael
florida for heaven's sakes
uh
but uh yeah i think i think i'd like to
be in on good times um
and i'd especially like to be there for
the episode where uh they did a funeral
spoilers james
james senior dies
yes
and uh
um
isabelle sanford no she was is about
stanford's on the jeffersons who was
florida florida that was their that was
her name but what in the show but what
was her name in real life no that's
that's the act that's the
because it was jim and james evans and
then i thought florida was his wife's
name yeah but what's the actress estelle
esther role yesterday thank you very
much
um
she gives the trump the one of the most
believable grieving performances i've
ever seen in my life
the damn damn day when she throws the
[ __ ] ball down and [ __ ] oh my god
that still like haunts me to this day
how she kept it together all through her
funeral
and then like you know when she's
cleaning up and they're like we can help
you mama and she's like i'm fine and
like we can help and though she's like i
said i'm fine and finally she like
breaks down and you can see
how how much she's at a loss you know
how [ __ ] the loss of gym she was such
a rock for everybody and then [ __ ]
she just
broke down man such a great performance
um yeah i would and also [ __ ]
i mean maybe a lot of kids weren't there
in the 70s but [ __ ]
jj was huge man
get dynomite like i'd be friends with
him that'd be cool
um you know there's a part of me that
wanted to say facts of life but like
um
i think i think i think good times i
mean there's also a part of me as like
silver spoons because he had an arcade
in his house and a little train
obviously that's delta that is dope but
still [ __ ] good times they were good
times man not getting hassled not
getting hustled keeping your head above
water making a way when you can
temporary landings layoffs good times
easy credit offs good good times
scrapbooking surviving
good times i slow down a chow line
oh
i didn't know that one it's not ain't we
lucky we got them
good times honestly i learned more
about life from that show than i did in
school
about interpersonal relationships and
that families can like be bickery with
each other and stuff like that it was a
good show
it's a next month's show it's an
excellent yeah i don't know if that's a
world that i'd want to live in other
than i believe that florida evans can
cook her [ __ ] ass off you'd eat well
in that house
but
very true except for the one episode
where
they they didn't eat because they were
afraid that the lady made a meatloaf
with dog food
that's another episode that haunts me to
this day
where i'm like that's a possibility i
had no idea and i'll be honest with you
probably wouldn't even notice if you
were going to town and [ __ ] but like i
remember being a kid and being like wait
a second and it's a really sad episode
about how like the they're all
rumored out that like this lady can't
afford anything so she eating dog food
and then she like they finally she
figures out that like they're not eating
her food because they think of my dog
and she gives this heartbreaking
monologue about like do you think i
would do that to my friends and they all
feel like [ __ ] i'm telling you important
life lessons i got from [ __ ] good
times i'm a good kid because of good
times taught me a better person i
remember catching an episode of good
times like a year ago during the
pandemic and i'm just like slapping
channels with nothing else to do
and there was an episode where where
michael
um flunks i think what was like a
standardized test
and so florida and jim have to go to the
school
and like
shout down their teacher says well
listen michael just might not be smart
enough he's like well look at the bias
of this test and it was all about you
know
testing biases all about the cultural
biases that the tests were
in the late 70s by the way in the late
70s the idea that how would this child
know how long it takes to get from
greenwich to
to boston like how would he know like
there are no references in here that you
can understand like this test is is is
actively biased against
people from the city and it's more
favoring people from that country people
feeling old people with money
and i was like [ __ ] they're talking
about this in the 70s
and we're still now beginning to have
real conversations about how the sats
are a rigged test
um meant designed to keep certain people
out of higher education
go for it good times you get yours they
do i mean this is this th it was a
powerful sitcom they they tackle a lot
of [ __ ] issues you know they didn't
do very special episodes every episode
would add some [ __ ]
real to it and stuff
yeah man
good ass show what's yours
my choice is a show that tackles zero
issues
frasier
i want to live in fraser's world
everyone everyone's erudite everybody's
got money they're eating at the finest
restaurants he does a [ __ ] podcast
for work ultimately
the hardest part of his life is his dad
who's gotta live with a stinky chair in
the living room but everything else is
perfect
like
that's a good [ __ ] life like he's got
what is that seattle this crazy [ __ ]
apartment in seattle that nobody can
actually afford
like that's easy street man that's
that's [ __ ] high on the hob living
and uh and i could i could get down i
could get used to that i could get used
to just like what are we doing today
we're gonna get on this [ __ ] radio
show and give people some advice
that's all answer some questions maybe
people give away tickets maybe we won't
yes
you're surrounded by emmy winners on
that show that show that like on so many
[ __ ] emmys and whatnot it was one of
those like they have to stop putting
themselves up for enemies because they
kept winning them all
and so
yeah yeah oh there were no very special
episodes of frasier but
i seek a drama-free life
i want to live like you know a rich
white gay couple
even though i know good god knows
jesus niles
um that's my pick that's my pick and uh
and that person will get a couple of
tickets to go see john williams sunday
live hollywood bowl
who was the winner again jc uh
laura mays
from where
from orange county
you're gonna have to drive up to holly
weird but [ __ ] it's gonna be worth it
because you're gonna go
see the maestro at work
send um
send me a dm idea
oh send you i can do it
yeah
send
yeah
just to cover your bases
and we'll get to we'll get you those
tickets to suite for sunday night
um thanks to the good folks at sounding
point la
and the uh the la philharmonic and the
the wonderful folks at the hollywood
bowl
for sponsoring that particular question
and offering us a delightful products
um we do we thank those with those cats
and we thank these cats
who are sitting around watching us all
this time and whatnot do you have a good
time watching us
doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] what are they
talking about i'm gonna judge it where i
agree with it is that what you've not
even
[Laughter]
have you been this have you been this
well then it must be a typical episode
of fat man beyond that uh thank you for
joining us kids um uh it's always fun
to sit around and [ __ ] and chit-chat
about
things that we don't have anything to do
with but can't wait to [ __ ] see
um don't forget
clerks three
it's happening you can't [ __ ] stop it
cannot try as you might see it with me
uh on the convenience tour or see it
without me when it plays at fathom
events participating uh theaters
uh from september 13th to september 18th
tickets at clerks3
dot movie i can't wait to see you all
out on the road and whatnot i'll be the
one up front wearing a white hat
uh what you got what you got mark what
you got what you've got um what do i
have next week i think is d23
is that happening that is happening
that's real world right real world
that's we're in the anaheim convention
center
celebrating all things disney and i know
they'll announce some cool marvel [ __ ]
probably um i think they will i think
there's there's a couple of they like to
meet out their their big announcements
and so i think they've got d23 like
comic-con was a thing clearly and
fighting came out there and announced
everything happening from here to
kingdom come there were some slots on
that sort of
final phase slide that were kind of open
and i'd have to think of getting in some
of that information
at d23 as well as potentially have an
investor day i think in in november
of this year um
but i will be there um with the good
folks at skydance new media and marvel
games to talk about a thing
on friday um
i think that's all i got in the
immediate future
legacy movie trailers in chat says
thanks guys great show
uh indy 5 trailer
gonna drop at d23
that's a good place for it james
mangold's movie hey banff man you got
some info there we may know who cut that
trailer
we do indeed that's right man
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] so we're gonna get to
see it
i still think that
remember when he said uh he was like
little children
that was the trailer for him
i went and re-watched little children
like
wonderful
at first i watched the trailer because i
was like oh he's right it's pretty good
trailer but then i watched the whole
last movie which i've always [ __ ]
loved man
that guy just disappeared after that
movie todd field yeah
yeah i think he's got a movie in like
venice
is this here yeah yeah i think he came
out of retirement or self-imposed exile
or whatever it was i i [ __ ] love
little chil this i don't wanna get
quoted out of context uh but i love the
movie little children the top fields
yes let's be very specific
um yeah it's good [ __ ] watch man and
he when he pointed that trailer out i
was like [ __ ] yeah yeah and watching
that trailer did and he was right he
goes i like to go for a feeling
uh what was our editor friend's name
we keep talking about him he
he
[ __ ] i can't remember
which i feel bad about it but i'm sure
somebody
in chat philip doll just did the joke
breaking smith loves little children
there it is
e.r mixon's craziest theories in chat
wrote zasalov can't stop clerks 3.
uh nobody's uh i know their chat's
always a little be honest but nobody
remembers was andrew
hegel heagle h-e-g-e-l-e
yes
andrew yeah guy yeah so now it's popping
up in chat like crazy
um yeah man buggin
he cut that indy trailer
well he he did say that he was like
working on a dream thing the thing that
that you know
oh he didn't say it but but you read
between the lines yeah we we all kind of
put that together the the steel trap
minds of this transfer
he named the dog indiana
nice
yeah
that's true
um kids
that's it
that's it that's all i can stands
because it can't stands no more we got
no more show for you there's literally
[ __ ] no show left we're out of it
it's done
all good things come to an end and all
shitty things come to an end as proven
by the show coming to an end kids did
you have a good time
if you did you got to thank jc bamf man
takes his time to make sure this here
broadcast gets to you out over the
internets using digital magic of some
sort you want to pay him back you want
to thank this man go to his [ __ ] bar
and drink drink booze
at his bar eat foods
eat the foods and drink the booze at his
butt scum and villainy cantina right
there in hollywood on hollywood
boulevard
um we won't be back there doing a show
for a minute but uh in december you
better believe
better believe we'll be there
uh did you like this show kids
if you did it's all because of the other
guy man give it up for marvelous mark
bernard and ladies and gentlemen so
inside
so smart so
insightful so smart
whenever i i was just at uh
fan expo canada last weekend
a lot of people came up to when i was
signing stuff and taking pictures and
they were like oh my god thank you
for fat man beyond that saved me during
the pandemic like
i was like that was the one that was the
show like oh i'd listen to you guys
every week i watch it every week and i'm
always like uh is the other guy isn't
mark great like yes he's so smart but
like it's nice that you like everything
you get you get smart i get
he likes everything like he's like mikey
from live stream
um but
people it was very nice meeting people
who like engage with the snow
in on a regular basis thank you folks
for engaging with the show on a regular
basis indeed that's all the show we got
for you i'll see some of you
out on the road on the convenience tour
and uh we'll figure out when we're doing
this streaming thing
next time also from the [ __ ] road
next time you see me streaming the show
i won't have this amazing background
that i always have
indeed i know you have to take those on
the road you got to pack up all the pops
i am i'm bringing all these [ __ ] pops
so i can set them up behind me wherever
i go
uh no i'll probably be in some dank
hotel bathroom like i've been kidnapped
i'll be holding up newspaper with the
date on it
looks like it's the book of life
chained to a radiator
there's a saw just out of reach
um yes that's exactly what life on the
road is like um but until then kids
keep your feet on the ground and keep
reaching for the stars
we will also try and slot in some black
man beyond
pods in the interim i have some some
thoughts of some guests that we can
bring on and chat about some [ __ ] but
they're right and i should be doing that
at the bar
you know i think we'll we'll as as makes
sense to do at the bar um i think some
of them will be doing here on the on the
zooms but yeah i think we'll we'll drop
into scum and villainy every now and
again
and uh and drinking a drink and tell
some jokes
might get malcolm barrett back and see
other things that watchman is as black
as
um
the uh rob brown in chat said i saved
people during the pandemic by liking
everything smith says
power of my heart
very randomly lewis yarod wrote those
funko pops will not be worth profit
until at least 2055.
like
okay math uh however i can tell you
right now logan like i've got some of
the rarest kevin smith pops in the world
they go for like 200 bucks so
you're instantly wrong
why would you end the show like that
everything was going great
until you had to get all funko pop smart
at us
also the comic books i have are not
worth anything anymore thanks yeah
really
uh there it is kids
[ __ ] go out
and live your dreams unless your dreams
are about hurting people killing small
things don't [ __ ] do that there's
enough of that just happening naturally
and [ __ ] don't don't be a part of that
don't be destructive be creative
dreams come true and make those dreams
fun dreams that everybody can enjoy
a good time like dream in color forms
kids who don't [ __ ] like color forms
a bunch of people out there going what
are color forms well we used to play
with them in the 70s they weren't a toy
they weren't a diorama i don't know what
they were but it stuck they were plastic
you put onto other plastic and it just
stuck there and it might look like a
figure of a thing that you know that was
what we called [ __ ] fun
and we turned out just great
yes we had wooden blocks we had colorful
we had a view master which is lincoln
logs [ __ ] slinkies
uh
there we had that phone that rolled and
its eyes went like this oh my god
we had full microphones that were just
plastic cones that sound like they were
amplifying your voice but it was just
literally a [ __ ] plastic cone you
were just fooling yourself
we were like can you hear me now
yes
and we had our genitals kids
yeah that's what this house still got
oh yeah
proud to say still got mine
still works mostly like just like han
solo's blaster
i never lost it
it comes at night mostly
mostly
ant-man is back for one last thought
last thing did you see that han solo's
blaster from a new hope just sold for a
million dollars
are you [ __ ] me yeah they had it on
display at comic-con and it's just sold
at auction for a million bucks
who owned it
i don't know it was like some
prop house was or uh
somebody very wealthy right now [ __ ]
uh i wouldn't be surprised if it was
dave mandel he owns a lot of [ __ ] um
but what if it was harrison ford it was
just like the amazing home like i've
been holding on to this for a long time
well what if he bought it though what if
he was like i want to have it back i've
been seeing that thing in 25 years well
he could certainly afford it that's
right
chewy it's cooler
it's kind of sweet i like your version
better than mine my version is just like
i'm selling this [ __ ] how much can i get
for this on the street
a desperate
i need a new plane i need some
plain fuel
i've heard the best story i've been i've
been doing a very quick deep dive into
brett goldstein's podcast films to be
buried with i was on it i know i
listened to your episode it was lovely i
had a such a good time that was before
i'm you know [ __ ] ted lasso and
i remember when i was watching till the
last so i was like i think i was on a
podcast with that guy and i loved his
podcast he was so fun and clever and so
attract when i not only was he an actor
and ted lasso but he is also a writer on
ted lasso he is indeed um but uh and so
my new quest is to be a guest on films
to be buried with does he still do it
does he still does it he still does it
and so i listened to it
that's so charming to me because he
could like that guy's a [ __ ] star now
he could have easily dropped the podcast
i'm so glad he still does it and he
still does it but he had an episode with
patton oswalt
who told this story about um and i
wonder if banff man can verify this
that
the the during the filming of empire
strikes back there's a scene
when when they first land in bespin and
you know
[ __ ]
leia and han get off of the millennium
falcon and they greet han solo and they
are so smart i mean lando and they are
so smiley and happy and just genial
and it's like the story is the night
before
they were at eric idol's house like
getting drunk
this is this is pat and oswald's words
doing rails of coke and then they
realized that it was so late that it was
worthless to go to sleep so they went
straight from eric idol's house to the
stages in in in england and then just
shot and so that's why they're so
[ __ ] goofy and silly because their
highest kites wow and i thought that was
just
beautiful
they brought a little hoth with them it
sounds like indeed
i have heard that story but it may have
been
via patton oswalt
um i'll say this have you ever seen
there's like a meme going around on the
internet and it was like once you see it
you can't unsee it
and it's the scene in return of the jedi
when they're heading to endor and leia
comes up behind han on the shuttle and
puts her hand on his shoulder
and all of carrie fisher's fingernails
are like
cut really low except for her pinky
which is like
an inch long
good look at [ __ ] look at batman
throwing the [ __ ] shade
i
that's the internet that's not me yeah
and also carrie was pretty open about to
i don't think i'm outing her
yeah i was gonna say everybody i think
that carrie made it's a big part of like
who she was to be like hey i used to and
now i don't she's very frank about it
and funny as well
um how wonderful that we got to
i crossed over with her a little bit
i did
the show i won't end no
it just won't stop we gotta stop it kids
uh there it is there's all the show
uh there's your fat man beyond uh for
this week uh
for fat man beyond i'm kevin smith and
i'm mark bernard tune in next week same
fat time same fat channel spodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith clerks three dot
movie for tickets jeff's kiss everybody
have fun on the road my friend thank you
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith